foreign
good morning everybody
um the education committee is ready to
go ahead and start hearing bills today
uh what I would like to do is just
beforehand give you a little update on
how many bills we do have and what's
happened in the last 24 hours
we have a total now of 91 bills
last night I vacated 564. that's a bill
that came to this committee
and it dealt with the state building
code and the state fire code
and why that came to education
I don't know but we no longer have that
and that's going to the proper uh
committee we do have two new bills 651
and 654. one deals with Alternative
forms of transportation to and from
school and the other deals with the
one-year certification for uh teachers
which could be extended at two years
that was the late bill which we had
approval from rules to enter and so that
one is now on our list too so 651 and
654 are added to our our list of bills
so that told us uh not 91 bills there is
one bill out there that has not been
assigned I don't know the number I don't
know what the content's all about maybe
we can have a lottery to see if that is
one for education or some other
committee like AG I don't know but it
could be fun so with that I'd like to
get in today's hearings I will be
presenting the first three bills myself
so I will have represent cordelli
running the meeting in the morning here
when we introduce see spells and so I'm
going to just remove myself from the you
know chair here and get set the
introduce uh 419 here's the gavel
thank you Mr chairman uh the first bill
we will hear this morning is House Bill
419 relative to the math learning
communities program of the community
college system and making an
appropriation there for
and um
we have two speakers thus far and
um
thank you
chairman Ladd as the prime sponsor will
introduce the bill
s access
foreign
good morning to the education committee
uh for the record my name is Rick Ladd I
come from Grafton that's now a change
District it represents Haverhill Benton
Landau Piermont and Warren I'm here
today to introduce
hb419 this is a bill that deals through
the math learning communities program
that's offered through the community
college system and there's an
appropriation therefore on this bill so
I'd like to walk through a little bit
very quickly here some of the
information that I noted on the sheet
that you probably are now in possession
of
um so let me start
the question you might ask is why the
why is there a need for uh 419 the math
learning communities program this is a
program that we started a number of
years ago and it was funded through a
grant which the community college system
had
and the individual in charge that is
Beth Doran she's out parking a car right
now so she will be testifying also today
um the the bill had a purpose and that
was to try to address the issue of where
we were with teaching of mathematics and
the learning of math skills and
knowledge throughout K through 12.
specifically in the high school
so in looking at the Box on this sheet
that I handed to you there is a box and
it has a number of bullets there the
first bullet talks about what happened
back in January 12 with the New
Hampshire math Task Force if you are
came to the legislative oversight
committee there was a discussion
regarding this this was a task force
that was put together by the Department
of Education and Paul leather who is the
Deputy Commissioner of Education chaired
that bringing in Math teachers
throughout the state and those other
associations which were interested in
looking at where we where we were at
that time and where we wanted to project
ourselves in terms of mathematics
mathematics skills and knowledge taught
in the schools
you can see the quote there that there's
many quotes and many recommendations
well over 20 recommendations that came
out of that report some of which we've
already adjusted and adopted one of
which was embedding mathematics into a
fourth year of instruction at the high
school we have we have done that
so here at New Hampshire must reverse
the disturbing trend of poor mathematics
performance
in its high schools and minimize the
need for remediation at the
post-secondary institutions that was
identified back in 2012. we're seeing
students going from our high schools
into the community college system
and over half of those students needed
Remediation in mathematics and of that
group that needed remediation half never
graduated with a two-year ticket
from the post-secondary schools so we
were certainly observing a difficult
situation and one needed support and
Improvement back in 2012.
in 2013 the house education committee 18
members on the committee that were here
signed a note communicated to the
commissioner of Education that high
school students receive math instruction
each year while enrolled in secondary
education
so we acted on that and put that in the
statute and now we have that in place
the New England Board of Education
higher education it's quote right here
savings and earnings benefit benefits
from reduced need for Remediation in New
Hampshire could benefit the state
economy by 16 million dollars we saw all
the money which was poured in for these
kids taking as students adults taking
Remediation in the community college
system of which many never made it just
think of the dollars and tuition dollars
which were lost and didn't really
benefit those students and did not
benefit our Workforce
65 to 70 percent of students planning to
attend Community College are unprepared
for the first college-level Math course
that was stated back there in the years
we were talking about 2013-14
October 2022 in the Wall Street Journal
AC test scores for college admissions
fall emissions uh fall for the fifth
year in a row this is the first time
quote the average score dropped below 20
out of 36. since 1991 so we were
dropping significantly on the ACT we're
also seeing that on the SAT
another bullet New Hampshire nape report
card October 2022.
New Hampshire students test scores fell
during the covet pandemic continuing a
long-term decline yes we understand we
know that there's many reasons why they
dropped during covet
if you're not they're getting eyeball to
eyeball instruction from your teacher if
you're not present if you're learning
online if you have that opportunity
there was reason and a lot of reasons
why the student scores did fall
the biggest decline both nationally and
in New Hampshire was in the eighth grade
math
according to 2022 assessments taken by a
sample of students 30 percent of the
state's 8th graders and 40 percent of
fourth graders are proficient or above
in mathematics that came from nhpr
and that was a report that was released
so we're we we need to have more
students proficient and we need to do
something about the remediation how we
can get things going and we've taken
some of the Monies to which we talked
about just yesterday the eser monies and
applied that to Paris and trying to
identify with mathematics programs and a
lot of that and excuse me is working we
are seeing an increase throughout the
state and it might be noted that in all
the 50 states we're not we're on the top
four
so but we're still not where we want to
be I can remember when I was first here
and I had a friend who was the agent
General over at the National Guard here
he went to Fort Sill in the class ahead
of me
and he told me he said Rick
when we're looking for people to Young
students to get into the National Guard
especially in the area of artillery
we now look to and it was a combined
Battalion between West Virginia and New
Hampshire and we looked to get all the
technicians from New Hampshire not West
Virginia because we believe the students
come out have good work ethic and they
have better mathematics however we don't
have the bar where we want to have the
bar yet either
48 of students proficient in math 2019
38 of students proficient in math in
2021.
and I have attachments if you look at
the attachments back in 14 15 16 and 17
we talked about following cohorts
yesterday the new on the I uh I research
and I platforms we saw how we can now
access and follow a cohort of students
as fourth graders fifth graders 6th
graders seventh graders
you can see how this is a rough uh
example of what I had you can see what
it looked like in the class of 2014. in
2010 that class was at the 65th
percentile
when they left at the middle school then
you jump into the high school level 2013
that class same group 37th percentile
you can jump through and see what 15
looks like also
2010 as 7th graders 66.
8th graders 65 jumping ninth and 10th
because we do not do a state assessment
in grades 9 or 10 36 percentile
2016 you can track it there sixth
graders 72 percent
sixth grade 66 percentile 7th grade
eighth grade 67th percentile 2015 37th
percentile
this trend has been going on we can't
kid ourselves saying it's all pandemic
related it's not and I think we all know
that so how do we and you can look at 17
it's the same story there for those
students in 17 fifth grade they started
the 74th percentile by the time they're
taking the SAT it's on the 40th
percentile but note that the eighth
grade the scores haven't dropped
significantly so there's a drop right
after the middle the waterfall effect
comes after the middle school but in
talking with Math teachers I believe
that we are also having some issues as
we go through the Elementary grades too
and that's where it comes there's a
number of issues which we want to be
looking at as an educator as a teacher
as the school principal for years and
years too many to count
that's that Modern Man to to count we
know of all about Maslow's hierarchy we
know about Bloom's taxonomy but we also
know there's an area called teaching
styles and learning styles just because
we have kids which are not proficient
doesn't mean they can't learn
what it means is we perhaps are not
teaching and connecting with the student
in terms of teaching style and learning
style
some people are very visual oriented
some people can listen very well I'm
more of a visual person
and and uh there there's a lot of
different ways of learning I'm also very
abstract random where my materials if
you look at my desk up there sometimes
materials are all over it I'm just not
that type of organized not a concrete
sequential person like some others maybe
so what we have done with the math
learning communities and this is very
very important
we developed a process I should say we
Beth Dorian and Company at the community
college system and working very many
long hours to try and present some kind
of a program to offer support to the
high schools so that we have this
transition
from secondary to post-secondary where
we don't have as much remediation where
we have the courses which they come out
which will qualify them for uh
post-secondary certification in
mathematics so what we did we knew that
in the 10th grade you're taking algebra
one
and following algebra one in the spring
well of course is not over yet it was
decided that we would give what we call
the accuplacer the Next Generation
accuplacer which is an assessment very
much aligned with the expectations of
community college system and
post-secondary education in terms of
mathematics
we also found out that there's many
students that don't learn the way like
the learning styles and the teaching
styles and there's a fear a fear that's
been generated through the Elementary
grades right up through so algebra one
they're not ready to go on to the other
levels of Mathematics algebra 2.
but we shouldn't just say well you're
not going to make it so we're just going
to give you a c and pass you on and they
really don't have those skills to really
be effective in the workplace
so what happened at with that next
Generation uh accuplacer test given in
the latter part of the algebra 1 to 10th
grade
it was seen that some students didn't
score at the level I'm sure that Beth is
she here she's behind me great thank you
Beth we'll tell you exactly how that
worked but the students took this
assessment and those is scored at a
certain level were seen as they're going
to have difficulty with algebra 2 but
if we provide another way of teaching
another way of learning which applies
and establishes how to reason in
mathematics how to apply this math and
use it in life skills perhaps we can get
along the road further
so Beth worked with a number of high
schools there were 38 high schools at
that time which participate in the
program I've got the list attached in
your your packet there it shows them
they're scattered throughout this state
and we started seeing some gains some
wonderful things occurring as far as
understanding and losing that fear of
mathematics
problem is then we as a state
decided not to fund it any further after
the grant dried up two hundred thousand
dollars it was lost
so if a student went off into this
course rather than algebra two they went
in you see what right there the next
course with Advanced mathematical
foundations
as that states right there applied
reasoning and practical applications of
the skills that they have so they went
that direction
then they would go on to the next level
as a senior so that the foundational
skilled mathematics was taught in the
11th grade to 12th grade the program had
a course called quantitative math
if you came out of quantitative math and
passing that with c and hitting the
skill levels that are expected and I'll
let Beth handle that then you satisfied
that mathematics credit for college in
the community college system
so and we found that there were a number
of students that were able to go this
route rather than having to go into the
other courses of you know they weren't
definitely not ready for trade or
calculus when I took my trig I took it I
and I passed it but where I really
learned it is when I was an fo in
Vietnam and I was surveying some of the
survey uh the ins the howitzers to get
them in on and I was able to triangulate
and use my cosine sine tangent all that
and it came out so I quickly put it
together I wanted to get out of where I
was so I quickly learned it there was a
reason for it there was no reason for me
to learn this stuff while I was in high
school I was more interested in
basketball
so we have this this program and I'm
hoping that we can continue and pursue
and reinstate this program and give
support it's interesting to note this is
teachers teaching teachers this program
the two hundred thousand dollars takes
care of that that amount of money needed
for the materials which are provided in
the accuplacer but it also provides what
I think is most important training
during the summer time where teachers
will provide a stipend those Math
teachers teaching this have a stipend to
come down to the community college
system and work with a team there a team
of folks which are applying this and
using it and learning from the people in
the field that have been successful in
this this is a wonderful opportunity for
us to address those remediation needs we
have without having to
rewrite everything that we have some of
the some of the elements needed to do
this in place in our schools right now
the key to this is let's get folks
trained let's give them the opportunity
to learn how to teach this and let's get
teaching styles matching with learning
styles so I'll conclude my testimony on
that if there are any questions I'll be
glad to take them
and thank you any questions from the
committee
yes representative Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question I was
wondering if um I know this afternoon
we're having a bill on uh dyslexia
testing and there is a a recent well not
recently but a a defined learning
disability called uh dyscalcula where
students are unable to actually
um their brain cannot form calculations
and numbers and it leads to math anxiety
and so on and I know the dyslexia
testing now is going to be down in the
Elementary grades I'm just wondering if
perhaps as part of this bill
um that testing at an early age because
we know if they they have reading
anxiety or math anxiety they just don't
you know it follows them right up
through the high school whether that
would be a good thing to add thank you
representative Tanner I I've looked at
the bill you're speaking about where I'm
looking forward to hearing it because we
have dealt with dyslexia on the
committee before one we all recognize
and I can remember it was Jack Balcom
that really pushed this uh and and
served on the special education advisory
Council that also recognized it and
supported it I said I I want to hear I I
haven't heard the uh all ins and outs of
that bill but I'm really looking forward
to to add that language onto this bill
this is something which has a physical
note which is directly associated with
this particular program this particular
program is already in statute if you
look at statute you're going to find
this program
from my perspective I think dyslexia is
strong enough to stand on itself and
that we can you know address this issue
I can remember as a youngster in school
I had a very difficult time with that
and when I got stressed out and I was
always stressed as a youngster in grade
one and I can't remember any my teachers
names I remember my principal's name Mr
McClay up in Toronto and he had a
leather strap I remember in the strap
but that so I was really a stressed out
kid and I oftentimes was reversing my
B's and D's and of course I was a U.S
citizen learning how to say the word
Bean versus bin and and neighbor oh you
are and all this and I was really messed
up in terms of my spelling so and and I
believe that I when I got stressed I
started to reflect some of the
characteristics of Dyslexia so I look
forward to that I I would wait and let
before I remarked to that or comment
represent Tanner I'd like to hear that
bill
um yes uh representative Damon
where it says oh I'm so sorry
so sorry thank you and thank you for the
thorough presentation simple question in
the actual text of the bill where it
references the total number of
uh the number of Summer Institute
participants is that referring to the
core of teachers that you spoke about
having summer training because I didn't
understand from the text of the bill did
it involved training teachers as well as
the opportunities yes it does and I
think representative those are the type
of questions that Shannon Reed is here
in Beth Dorian from the community
college system I think they're well
prepared to answer that thank you you're
welcome
represent representative the dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh what was the
original Grant what was the original
Grant from that was discontinued another
good question for them I know it was 200
000 I don't know where Beth I got that
dug it up and I but I can remember her
telling me when I met with her often
over there we're running out of the
fifth year we're running out and what
are you going to do as and I I remember
to representative wolf has also brought
a bill in not too long ago trying to get
that reinstated of which we didn't make
it we made it came out of this committee
but a strong vote uh Finance wasn't uh
too keen on it this is why we're it's
really incumbent upon us if we feel this
is something from a policy perspective
and we certainly know that there are
certain
gains made from this and we've seen it
in students before we need to follow it
all the way through all our committees
here to make sure that it's a successful
bill
yes representative Hall thank you Mr
Sharon thank you for taking my question
um on the 38 schools were they selected
or did they were did something wrong
it's voluntary and that's again another
issue about this was is the director of
that program so I would ask her how she
got them involved I know there was a lot
of communication amongst teachers you
know uh in different districts talking
with each other and seeing the benefits
of this program and teachers do
recognize learning style and teaching
styles extremely important and this this
program tries to address that
okay
seeing no further questions uh thank you
very much chairman LED
and uh next would be Beth Dorian from
the community college system
good morning everyone
my name is Beth Doran and I'm the
director of college access programs the
community college system and I'm going
to start I think with just a little
brief introduction to just follow up on
some of Representative lad's comments
and then answer the three questions that
were asked and then any further that you
may have so I think I just want to state
that we are in support and at ccs and H
strongly supports this bill and the
reasoning for that is because we we as a
system have been working with the high
schools for some time and trying to deal
with the issue of math preparedness when
students come to our colleges high
school students graduate and come to our
colleges and this is a long-standing
issue that we've been working on for a
number of time and and thought we had a
really good solution with the math
learning communities we've recently
changed recently within the last three
or so years how we handle Remediation in
within our colleges and prior to the
last three years or so students will put
in remediation courses which cost them
money and did not give them any college
credit because they were not college
courses they were mediation courses at
that time this program fit very very
well because we were able to Stave off
those remediation courses now what we're
doing is running something called
co-requisite math courses where students
placed in a traditional Math Course and
there may be a remediation component but
what we're still seeing is high school
students graduating and not having the
skills that they need in order to be
successful in an entry-level math
College course so in representative lad
contacted us and said you know what do
you think is there still a need for this
program and frankly from our end we knew
there was but I wasn't sure how the high
school folks felt so I reached out to
several of the high school teachers Math
teachers who were involved in the math
learning communities project when it was
before it ended several years ago and
they all said the same thing absolutely
this is absolutely still a strong need
in our high schools so going to
representative a lot and letting him
know that yes the high school teachers
felt that it was a strong need and as
well as our College faculty so again you
know we're very supportive of this bill
we think it's a great model it's nothing
Earth shattering or new and Innovative
it's just something that works and uh
just to elaborate a little bit on what
representative Ladd had said it is made
up of two courses the first being what's
called Advanced mathematical foundations
and what we had done back several years
ago was to uh do the accuplacer for all
students who
may have taken Algebra 2 and may not
have scored scored lower than a c or or
lower on algebra two and those students
were given the accuplacer and the
accuplacer we had determined a cut score
of 65 and if students scored below that
65 they would be placed into the
advanced mathematical foundations course
and what that is is honestly it's an
Algebra 2 course with some of the
concepts and I want to also state that I
am not a math expert I am not a math
teacher don't have a lot of math
experience but I was able to get an
advanced degree with a handful of math
courses intentionally but I I am uh have
quite a bit of experience with managing
and developing programs so when we put
um you know saw that these students
needed some more understanding of math
concepts specifically algebra and
potentially geometry as well our faculty
along with some high school teachers
developed this Advanced mathematical
foundations course and what it is
basically is a remediation course that
we would have have taught years ago if
students were to come into our colleges
and not perform well on the accuplacer
so it's a remediation course that's
taught in the high school for high
school credit and not college credit so
they're not receiving any college credit
but they're also not paying for any type
of mediation once they come to our
colleges
once they complete that that advanced
mathematical foundations course remember
these are students that scored below a
65 on the accuplacer they would take the
accuplacer again at the end of the
course and 95 percent of our students
had significantly higher score once
completing this course events
mathematical foundations is is really
based on habits of mind framework in
teaching mathematics which is a very
different way than mathematics is
typically taught if the students did
score above a 65 at that point which
again the majority of them did they
could then take quantitative reasoning
and this typically happened in the
either their junior or their senior year
depending upon how courses are run at
the high school whether they're a full
year or a semester-based course
so the quantitative reasoning is a
college credit course it's run through
our running staff program and students
high school students can take it on our
college campuses as well and that is a
course that is eligible in probably
about 90 percent of our degree programs
a requirement I should say so students
are able to take that course while
they're in high school for college
credit and then assist them with the
remaining information when they when
they come to our colleges for a degree
so that's sort of the you know an
overall understanding of the program and
and and why we think it's important and
referencing where the funding came from
initially we originally it was back in
2010 or 2012 I sorry apologize I've
neglected to look at my records before I
came but at that time it was funded by
the math science partnership and that
funding was not really very well I think
when it was originally started it was a
new and Innovative program and it made
sense and the math science partnership
funding back then was really based on
new and Innovative programming so at
that time it was new and Innovative as
it as it you know marched on throughout
its years it became a program that we
didn't make any changes to because it
worked very well and the math science
partnership funding really did not apply
any longer so we applied for something
called the college access challenge
Grant which was many many years ago and
that was a five-year grant that we did
receive but unfortunately we lost the
state actually lost their maintenance of
effort after three years and we lost the
funding after three years we went back
to the math science partnership got some
additional funding for them but again it
was not the best fit so that was the
history of some of the funding in the
past
somebody asked what the training to be
trained teachers and yes that was very
much a part of the program when when a
school signed on for to become part of
the math science part I'm sorry the the
math learning communities then those
teachers were expected to attend a
summer Institute we called it which was
once a year held in June as soon as the
school was out our high school teachers
and our College faculty would come
together and just share curriculum needs
and things of that so it can work
together in understanding how to best
teach this curriculum and the other
question I heard was uh was it voluntary
for schools and yes we did quite a bit
of marketing out to high schools just
presenting the program letting them know
what the program was all about and it
was completely voluntary for them to
sign on so we did have we started with
probably three or four schools and when
the program ended there were about 38
high schools that were participating
so I'd be happy to take any other
questions
uh thank you for your testimony uh
representative miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here uh so my my question is is
that if
the teachers are going through a
training program and a conversation
about how to teach math in a different
kind of a way
when they leave that summer program is
there then a common curriculum yes that
they then use back in their own own
school yes they are actually given the
curriculum that they should follow
there's very specific competency
helpline as far as what should be taught
so yes it's very structured
thank you very much Mr chair and thanks
Beth for uh for joining us uh yesterday
and today so um I'm sure if you could
sort of take me through
um just an example just so I understand
the flow that so I'm absolutely I so I
certainly support this I supported this
a few years ago when uh when it came
through as well but but if we did a
hypothetical example where you know Luke
Luna would take seventh grade math
eighth grade math and then in ninth
grade takes algebra and sort of doesn't
really like it in 10th grade algebra 2
doesn't really like it when's he when
does he
um uh when is he tested with the
accuplacer and then what's his plan for
like 11th grade okay great question and
um
this so I'm speaking now back from when
we a lot when we last had the program
from several years ago at least four or
so years ago and what we saw back then
was a student a traditional student
would come into high school and take
algebra one and then uh for for their
first year and then this is based on a a
high school that has a year-long course
as you know now we have there are a lot
of schools that go by semester but based
on a year-long course and then I can
talk about semester based as well
freshman year students would take
algebra one sophomore year it would be
algebra it would be geometry and then
junior year it would be algebra two so
we would catch those students at the end
of their junior year test them with the
accuplacer and then they would take
senior Math typical Advanced
mathematical foundations it was called
senior Math at one point so they really
wouldn't have a whole lot of time for
quantitative reasoning but in the
semester-based model students would come
in and take algebra one their their
freshman year and probably geometry in
their let's say first semester of
sophomore year in algebra two in the
second soft second semester of sophomore
year and the junior year we would test
them and then they would have the
opportunity to take the advanced
mathematical foundations in the second
semester of their junior year and then
they could take the quantitative
reasoning in their freshman year I'm
sorry in their senior year first
semester
and a follow-up on thank you
um and what I think I heard you say too
is that the the foundation's uh class
can um can be given as a running start
um the quantitative reasoning can
quantitative reason yeah the advanced
mathematical foundations is not a
college course it's not it's not a
running service all right great so they
they can exit high school with with
quantitative responsive reason and have
that apply great thank you
representative blackis
good
I think this is an awesome program but I
do have a question if in the past you've
come up with a program and you've done
all this work and you're trained
teachers I just want to understand what
the money that we are voting for the
upcoming years is how that is used in
making this program happen sure so the a
good part of the funding would be to pay
the salary for somebody to to to run the
program to be able to monitor it and and
run it the summer Institute is a a big
expense of the program and that's where
we're bringing all of the teachers
together we would also uh the funding
would also go to any curriculum needs
books and things of that so that the
high schools may need so if the high
schools don't have the appropriate books
that um then then the funding would be
able to pay for that as well
um it it also pays for stipends for High
School faculty as well as College
faculty to form an advisory committee so
that advisory committee meets monthly to
determine you know what the needs are
and what changes may need to be made and
they're in constant communication with
all of the high school teachers that are
running the program so it's it's quite a
bit of salary based you know mostly
because the program needs to be managed
but again also
um a lot of training as well
thank you
represent Pelzer
thank you thank you Mr vicer um
I'd just like to ask you who develops
the um the curricula for these programs
our math experts not me
um that would be our High School faculty
along with our College faculty in unison
thank you
representative kisscadden
thank you Mr chair
um just backing up on that Cur the
curriculum what grade levels is it
really intended for just middle to high
or does it start in early grades
um well it definitely built for high
school students okay uh for sure because
it's it's again we we're looking at
students who have not done well in
algebra 2. those those are the students
that we're focusing on students that may
have got a C or below if they're if
they're getting a c in Algebra 2 they
really don't understand the concepts and
the teachers are developing the
following the curriculum I'm sorry
follow-up yes well the the curriculum
has been developed so we've been using
when the program was in operation we
were using the same curriculum for it
did go through some modifications
specifically the college the
college-based course but we would need
to review all of that again which is why
you know if this bill were to receive to
pass and receive funding then we would
need to bring our math experts together
to review all of that curriculum again
but I don't see it changing to any great
degree
follow-up
uh thank you my question is on the
funding
it it would seem like if there were
great results that districts or
Community College would put that in
their local budget so it's sustainable
because we know grants kind of right you
know run out and is having a bill in the
table more of an assurance for funding
I mean it's a shame that results were
seen
and now we've got to reinvent the wheel
I feel bad about that yeah we really
need to rely on the high schools to to
be able to provide the the teachers and
that's I think you know a partnership
that's that's critical you know if we
have the funding we can train those
teachers and we can bring the teachers
together to ensure that what's being
what should be taught is being taught to
assist these students that that have
remediation needs but oftentimes you
know there are difficulties sometimes
with the high schools being able to
provide the teachers that are that are
needed so I can't speak to the high
schools and and the school districts as
far as financial needs but with this
funding we are able to bring all of that
together and really function well which
is why it's sort of kind of fell by the
wayside when when the program ended
because there was nobody there to
continue the just you know what what
what needed to happen to ensure that the
students were receiving both of those
course levels
representative pedernal thank you Mr
Sharon thank you for taking my question
as I look at these um achievement scores
I noticed the trend that in the younger
years the students do well and then as
the math gets in right exponentially
more challenging the scores start to
drop off and I certainly experience that
myself you know as a as a student a long
time ago so I feel like uh I should say
it appears to me that we're still
applying math education the same way as
it was applied
almost 40 years ago when I was in high
school so I'm wondering if maybe there's
something else missing in the students
in the education process that would help
the students learn to would help in the
ability to logically apply math skills
more to the abstract
basic math skills to the more abstract
Concepts so maybe there's something else
that we are missing that isn't
the hammer that we've been hitting over
students heads with me
very possible but as a community college
system what we're looking at as far as
what we see is students coming in as as
as high school graduates and not having
that level of math skill to actually
perform well in a college course so
that's our Focus follow up follow up
um yeah so I'm just saying if there's
something maybe or in the earlier years
it seems to drop off around 8th grade
right definitely because they
immediately jump into algebra and that
starts to become very abstract we'd be
certainly willing to look into that
thank you
Bonnie
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um my question follows uh representative
cascadden's um in terms of the
curriculum itself
um is there a cost associated with that
curriculum that eventually the districts
have to assume or is it just a change in
the delivery that you're teaching the
teachers to address the students needs
it's really a change in delivery like I
said we we work with the habits of mind
in teaching mathematics and I don't know
the specifics of that but
um that's really the focus so there's no
there's no cost at all no we provide all
of the curriculum to any any uh High
School signing on WE hand them the
curriculum and then provide continual
professional development for their
teachers thank you so no class of the
district just a quick follow-up yes I
assume that these two courses would also
go towards graduation requirements in
lieu of the other courses yes thank you
representative Hall
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'm wondering about it seems
like a problem here is teacher training
right mathematics teacher training so is
there any communication with the other
colleges the you know the our
universities that teach teachers I mean
I guess I'm wondering
why is this different why aren't they
being taught already when they're coming
out right their communication with the
higher ed
um we we do work with the university
system in in uh accepting the courses
such as quantitative reasoning to ensure
that the curriculum we have for our for
our college credit course which is the
quantitative reasoning will be accepted
at our university colleges but as far as
training teachers that's not something
we've we've specifically spoke with
Fourier universities on but I can tell
you that my daughter is an elementary
school teacher and took one Math course
her entire teacher training so I can't
speak to that but
um you know as I said we don't we don't
necessarily work with um the four years
on what that curriculum should look like
foreign
the practicality of this the
implementation date is
anticipated
um
these this course or series of courses
have to be embedded into current High
School curriculums approved by local
school boards
something will have to come out of the
math program because teacher's schedules
are already
um by this time at that point in July
are already set for the following year
um obviously and so there is there is a
cost to the school in terms of maybe one
less if you're teaching this course you
can't teach the other course
um I'm not suggesting that's bad I'm
just talking about the practicality of
it so I wonder if the the implementation
date
um what what is actually going to happen
in the next calendar year or when do you
see uh based on knowing that you have
these hurdles uh that actually would be
implemented in schools
sorry about that the first year would
definitely be a planning year so I would
see that
um if we were to start in even July the
first thing we would need to do would be
to hire a program coordinator somebody
who would coordinate the project and
then they would start their Outreach to
the high schools to see who could who
who is willing or interested in coming
on board so and and I would see that
occurring through December or so really
sort of understanding the landscape and
and seeing what schools may be
interested in coming on board and then
hopefully in that January working with
those districts to be able to prepare
for the fall so I see it also as more
options for high school students so
remember we're talking about a student
who is not typically a fan of math so
these are students who are not done who
have not done well in math courses so
it's giving them more options you know
these are not students who are going to
take calculus or or any or and do well
in it or any math course like that so
it's going to provide them with another
option to take a course that's going to
build on their math School SK skills and
then be able to take that college level
course just prior to graduating from
high school
follow-up thank you
um on the same same thinking then
if it's going to go into the high school
curriculum then my assumption is that
any student could take it right in
middle school and not necessarily be
going on to community colleges
correcting that for that piece
okay
um thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you
representative Hall thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my last question
um so these kids the schools that didn't
buy in do you think it was because they
already
already had foundations of math classes
you know if they weren't interested I
would suspect they just probably didn't
know enough about it or may not have
been ready to make a commitment for
whatever reason maybe they didn't feel
the districts didn't feel like they had
the capacity or the resources to
dedicate teachers as as you had
mentioned
um to that specific course or program I
think that would be my guess thank you
Progressive Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question do you think
um it it's my feeling that
um finding qualified Math teachers is a
problem in New in all schools Across the
Nation and certainly we have a teacher
shortage and
you know a lot of the Math teachers that
I knew that left the the uh profession
of teaching you know that their salaries
went up exponentially
um and they had a lot less struggles I
think but do you think uh the fact that
we have trouble with finding Math
teachers and perhaps the people that we
do find
may not have had much training at all
and and teaching that they just get a
emergency certificate or something like
that that that's part of the issue that
we need to look at at that
um this is possible I mean I remember
when when my own children were in high
school and they were they weren't great
at math either and there were a lot of
at that time there were a lot of
Engineers being laid off and a lot of
Engineers were coming in to teach math
and didn't have teaching skills
basically they knew math but they maybe
didn't know how to teach as well to a
student who was struggling so I'm sure
that may play into it in some ways but I
think that's where that's where this
program really helps as well because we
work with those teachers and helping
them to understand how to teach these
basic concepts in a different way
I can see no further questions thank you
very much thank you
and I don't believe there are any
further cards for uh HP 419 so I will uh
close the hearing on 14 actually before
uh 19 and we'll move uh straight into HB
which is relative to the availability
and funding for the Dual and concurrent
enrollment program by the community
college system and making an
appropriation there for
and uh
the introduction will be by the prime
sponsor uh chairman Ladd
Le
foreign
again to members of the committee
education committee uh for the record
again my name is Rick Ladd I represented
in Grafton 5 that is Haverhill and other
communities around Haverhill I'm here
today to as Prime sponsor of HB 420 the
availability and funding for dual and
concurrent enrollment program
this is again a program which deals
directly with our community college
system
and just as uh before I get into where
I'm going to say I want you to let you
know that behind me we do have the
chancellor for the community college
system uh Dr Mark Rosenstein and Shannon
Reed also from the community college
system which I'm sure will uh want to
address this uh I had written on the top
part of this I'm not gonna because I
know time is time and we've got to
hustle along here but uh why what is a
dual concurrent enrollment program you
can read through that and see some of
the statements which I referenced to
that a lot of that comes out of the
community college system
uh what changes are identified in this
bill is what I want to tackle right now
so we can get on to the professionals
behind me program offerings will include
other courses that are fundamental
necessary for success in post-secondary
education and career paths beyond the
current approved stem courses now what
we have now we do have a concurrent dual
enrollment program uh moving and very
active within this state we
going back a number of years I remember
when I worked with the the the
chancellor Ross cattell and also at that
time community college system I also
worked with the chancellor Todd Leach
from the University system New Hampshire
University system of New Hampshire was
not interested in this program at that
time
community college system recognized how
this program right here has so many
strengths and has moved forward and
really done a great job but what we have
now is we had a program back then
that was built on the first year 850 000
the second year 950 000 of the biennium
and due to the fact of limited resources
the cost of a course I believe was 150
bucks
um we we had only 10th 11th and 12th
graders participating in the program
since then we've expanded this to 10th
11th and 12th graders we've also
expanded the program and would like to
expand the program by way of Statute
here away from just the stem courses
there are many courses that high school
students have an opportunity to take
while in high school concurrent dual
enrollment where they're going to get
college credit simultaneously with their
credit their earning for graduation
and they may be taking a course that's
dealing with child care
at the college or they may be taking
some other course which is more of the
liberal arts but not the stem-oriented
type of course
I had a daughter when we were living up
in Alaska who took a course while she
was in high school through UAA
University Alaska Anchorage which had uh
components of that college throughout
the state
she took a course several courses while
she was at at the high school there in
town and those courses what she took
simultaneously with what she took at the
high school which she did get credit for
the courses which is taken at the high
school they applied to Elmira College
where she went off to college and later
down to the medical school in Charleston
where king of speech pathologist
audiologist
so what happened we saw her spark when
she took this course in child care from
UAA and she learned hey I can do this
and she didn't have all the confidence
in the world that's what this does right
here by STEM we are obviously going to
be opening it up to more students now
too in previous years it went from 850
000 a year 950 000 for the second year
of that biennium it's going up to 101.5
million dollars but now we're jumping
the number of students which can
participate they can take not just two
courses a year they take and can take
five college courses these three credit
courses
what happens when they take this and we
we have the proof of the pudding right
now that we have students doing this who
are coming out with one semester and
some two semesters accounts under their
belts before they even get to the
college doors
that's a tremendous savings that's
savings millions of dollars than part of
families in terms of uh the the expense
of courses at the post-secondary level
thank goodness the courses at the
community college system are a whole lot
less than the Arthur University system
New Hampshire and with a two plus two
program whereas you can take the two
years which we worked at with a language
last year and we've been working on that
for a number of years the course is
taken at the Community College Center
applicable and applied towards your
four-year degree
so there's a savings right there you
don't have to go to the four-year system
to pay oodle some money and that we know
that's really difficult and you look at
the kids coming out of the University
system right now
I guess we're second to UVM in terms of
college debt in this state for a
four-year degree
although we when it comes you hear the
University Systems speak that well we
may have a high debt but we have a very
low default rate so the kids from New
Hampshire and adults from New Hampshire
we pay our bills but we still come out
with a lifelong debt which makes it
extremely difficult when you get that
first job even to find housing or even
you know to make your limited payroll
take care of your daily uh costs so this
bill extends the dollar amount to 3.25
million dollars per year that will be
used for the number of students which we
have it will result in a tremendous
Savings in dollars to families and
students and adults at the community
college system so I'm I'm going to be
brief I think that's that you can read
everything on the bottom there
there was a report that I I pulled up
last night and looked at uh in Colorado
they did a research back in 2014 that's
now you know eight years old but
concurrent enrollment courses reduce the
need for remediation remediation at at
the college level by 11.2 percent kids
see they can do it and then we have a an
active number of youngsters and the last
thing I want to impart to you is that
we are one of the uh products that we
deliver to other states in the state is
our students for post-secondary
Education many go out to get their
education UMass Lowell at the University
of mass Amherst at Orono University of
Maine over to UVM they go and leave our
state of those students
less than half come back to our own
state to do their jobs and work so we're
losing our Workforce if we get kids
involved in this concurrent dual
enrollment in the high school and have
them go on to post-secondary education
in this state the likelihood of folks
staying in the state is higher
and therefore we have the workforce we
can't afford to lose any of these
students in this state we just don't
have enough to fill our Workforce needs
as it is right now so thank you very
much I'll be glad to answer any
questions thank you uh questions from
the committee representative woodcock
thank you Sharon good morning
representative again yeah um
structurally on the dual enrollment if a
student takes the a class it's a
two-part question actually if a student
takes a class here and under this
program I know it's transferable to our
community colleges how is it is it also
transferable as a college class say the
UVM or you own
asked Dr Rubenstein that I'm sure are
you going to come up okay there's the
man that you want to ask these technical
questions to I okay all right
yes yeah thank you
um if I understand uh Rick I'm looking
at lines three through 17. it's just the
number of courses expanding from two to
five yeah so is I mean is that
is it possible for a student to take 20
of these courses
yeah that's too for for their you they
could take it over the years that
they're they're doing a 10th 11th and
12th okay 20 courses and they could take
15 courses then
okay
that's high school math we're trying to
remediate high school math
okay then yeah anyhow 15 courses yeah
yes and but if a student wants to take
more than that they can do so but that's
on on their own ticket if they go beyond
the five in any given year and some are
doing that okay thank you thank you sir
representative cordiello
good morning thank you good morning uh
so my background is coming from
four-year colleges where pretty much all
of them have a required freshman
composition class I imagine the
community college system is similar in
having a requirement like that so would
this allow for students to fulfill that
requirement in high school then
maybe this is a question for well the
courses of course are concurrent it's
not stem
from this so I guess I also want to
state to you that the the instructors
which made me high school teachers
teaching this they must comply with the
same rigorous standards that a professor
or adjunct is required to have at the
post-secondary level as far as answering
your question specifically I think
that's a a good one for the staff behind
me
thank you any further questions from the
committee uh seeing none uh thank you
representative thank you
and next will be chance the Rubenstein
from the community college system
welcome back
good morning and thank you for having us
today thank you to representative Ladd
who said probably everything that that
we might think to say but I'll take a
few moments to elaborate
from the previous discussion about math
learning communities some of the
questions had to do with the challenges
that students face and the the flip side
of that for us dual enrollment one of
the benefits is challenge a student
who's looking for more rigor than they
can find the opportunity to pursue
college-level learning while still in
high school because they're ready for it
increases the likelihood that those
students stay engaged with their
education and have a sense of purpose
for going to school and we think that's
by itself beneficial
it's also encouraging on a couple of
fronts now one of those is a student
encourage pursue the things that they're
passionate about to learn more deeply
about the things that they care about
that may be outside of the normal High
School curriculum
but also the original intent of dual
enrollment programs running start was to
encourage consideration of
post-secondary education for students
who didn't believe that they could
pursue College didn't think that that
was going to be an opportunity whether
because they didn't believe they had the
ability or because they didn't think
they could afford it
in some ways that's still an important
part of this but not simply the
affordability I'll come back to that in
a second and part of this is is the the
affordability of time students don't
like to feel like they're falling behind
none of us do so the idea that you might
want to do something different After
High School whether it's military
service whether it's to pursue a
technical career whether it's to take
some time to think
the opportunity to pursue College while
still in high school to bank academic
credit toward a post-secondary degree
give students more time encourages them
to explore what makes sense for them
again coming back to the fundamental
early tenants one of them was in fact
affordability as representative Ladd
described this program saved students
and their families significant cost
this year we'll probably see students
pursue 40 000 credits through the
running Start program
if that's at our tuition rates about
nine and a half million dollars but
those students and their families will
pay less than two and for those who are
taking the salmon the salmon CTE courses
will pay nothing so in essence seven and
a half eight million dollars of value
transferred to those families in savings
through through this investment that you
make but as described earlier currently
the scholarship is for two courses a
year and to some degree that lends
itself to more
pick and choose more piecemeal approach
to this at five credits or five courses
a year rather a student can genuinely
pursue a Year's worth of college a year
and a half of college and if they choose
to do some of this during summer as well
can complete high school and
concurrently an associate degree and I'm
not suggesting any student needs to rush
to finish two years I'm going to be
lifelong Learners and they're going to
spend their careers continuing to learn
and reinvent what they need to know to
to adapt to changes in their interests
in technology and Industry
but if in those two three years of high
school with the challenge of dual
enrollment courses these students can
build that interest cultivate that
lifelong learning that that passion for
knowing then we can set them on a path
that when they're ready for the next
lesson the next thing they need to do
they're prepared to do it and they're
not carrying the significant debt that
has historically been accruing for New
Hampshire students we think this is an
opportunity to level the playing field I
had an occasion I think with this
committee before to reference the data
on free and reduce lunches this state
has a generation coming forward in high
school k through eight K through 12 now
who are going to find need and that need
may be a barrier if we can provide the
encouragement if we can demonstrate for
them an affordable pathway if we pair
this with last year's uh House Bill
1530s initiated by representative Ford
that builds Pathways from the community
college system the university system we
can ensure that this generation of New
Hampshire students has every opportunity
that any student in the country has
to live a good life and to pursue the
education they need to be full
participants as not just in the
workforce but as engaged citizens
informed citizens in their communities
so thank you
foreign
thank you Chancellor if I just uh would
like to add one thing and then be happy
to answer a couple of questions that
came up when representative Ladd was
speaking I just wanted to mention that
when when this program first started or
the first year or two once it really
sort of got its weight under it we saw a
35 increase in running start
registration running start being these
courses that are taught in the high
school by qualified teachers 35 increase
in the registrations with probably a
third of those or so happening in the
Manchester area and that really told us
that these were really benefiting
families that students that were living
in economically disadvantaged areas were
able to take these courses when they
didn't have the hundred and fifty
dollars to take those courses when they
weren't free so I think we've we've
definitely seen that uh the benefit of
of this program and with adding the
English composition and just moving away
from just them and CTE I think was your
question about English comp English comp
is our most popular running stock horse
it is just about every High School in
the state has it of course it's It's
Complicated by the fact that the the
teachers have to have the same
credentials as our adjunct faculty do so
they have to have an advanced degree in
math in English but it is our most
popular course and our most transferable
and the courses do transfer to we know
they transfer to well over 200 uh
colleges and universities across the
country
um but you know certainly mostly in this
New England area we don't see any
problem with transferability for the
most part
if I may add one last point and this
actually director doran's point about
academically qualified and
representative Ladd also referenced them
the requirements for the teachers who
participate in this program and goes to
representative Tanner's question about
finding qualified faculty part of what
we're requesting here is not just the
scholarship support but program support
because we'd like to be able to test
some different approaches to doing this
in some cases there are students in high
schools where the teachers are not
academically prepared to offer the
college level courses based on our
accreditation requirements so can we be
more creative and engaging with our own
faculty to deliver programs can we get a
little bit further outside the the
framework that was originally
established to ensure that students
regardless of high school have access to
these programs
thank you uh representative miler thank
you Mr chair could you please
um expand on the concept of
what is needed for a teacher in the high
school to basically teach these
particular courses what what is the
difference between that high school
teacher Visa be that of those who are
aligned with the running Start program
for example so it really depends on the
course that's being taught there are
different levels but traditionally let's
say for a major level a a academic
course such as English math History
Science those teachers will need to have
a a master's degree in that particular
content area so a teacher will need to
teach math they'll need a master degree
in math not just a master's degree in
educational leadership or something like
that but in math if they don't have that
master's degree we will accept a
master's degree in something else such
as educational leadership plus 12
graduate credits in that particular math
content area so it's either the full
Masters or 12 graduate credits thank you
for that clarification
I think representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair thanks for
joining us this morning
um this may be I don't know if you've
got got this at
um at the ready or maybe uh maybe
Shannon has has this but um but um was
there an appropriation in the current
budget for um for dual and concurrent
and what how much was that
9.5
per year
um and so so follow up on on this Mr
chair so this one yes bring me up to a
3.25 and um of the of the 1.5 was there
any um uh any of that that was not
utilized by um students
a few years ago yes because when as I
mentioned just pre-pandemic
um when we had the 35 increase all that
funding was spent when the pandemic hit
the running start registrations took a
pretty big hit as well
um they decreased significantly for a
variety of different reasons that we'll
get into here but we're just climbing
out of that now so uh we anticipate that
this year we will spend all of that
funding by the end of June okay good and
and just a quick follow-up on quick
follow-up
um uh just to be sure uh when the when
uh and I hope this this works out
exactly how you you said that you expect
this to be used up
um if if the program's over subscribed
are any students turned away or um or is
it just a you know it
something happens that's a great
question because that did happen
um a few years back and we did work with
the Department of Ed to access some
additional funding so no students were
turned away okay fantastic thank you uh
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question several years ago the
virtual Learning Academy Charter School
had an agreement with Southern New
Hampshire University where the students
could take
dual enrollment courses and graduate
with an associate's degree is there any
potential for an option like that did
you take that
me
certainly yes we would love to and we
actually are doing some things like that
with uh with the New Hampshire Career
Academy where students are able to come
to our colleges and take
um actually enroll in our colleges for
the associate's degree and we also have
something called the e-start program not
sure if you're familiar with that but
this falls into this bill as well estart
is uh courses that are taught 100 online
by our faculty so we offer up to 30 of
those courses per year for students to
take so that's another and that also is
in conjunction with velac so velax
offers the high school credit and we
offer the college credit so that would
be another way for students to earn
significant credits follow-up yes thank
you
um so in order to
have that degree conferred would
students have to leave their public
school and attend take vlax classes no
how would that no no for each start
they're actually still enrolled in their
high school they just happen to get the
high school credit from viva acts that
they then transfer to their High School
that question does also point to part of
the reason why we're looking for some
flexibility and we describe a number of
different pathways
as my colleague described we have
partnership with velax when we do some
things with Charter school but
ultimately we want to give students as
many options as possible one of the
reasons that we tend to prioritize
running stars that allow students to
stay in their high schools and our
experiences that the majority of
students Thrive more in that setting not
every student but for a lot of students
they prefer to be able to engage in the
other aspects of high school life while
not giving up this opportunity for
Challenger and rigor
foreign
thank you sorry Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question I'm
wondering if there's a minimum
enrollment in the courses and schools
that are a small student population are
there issues at any times in terms of
the school being well willing to offer
the course
because there's not that many students
who might take it not typically we do
have a minimum enrollment of five but
we've years ago that was somewhat of an
issue but we really haven't experienced
that lately thank you
yes representative McDonald thank you
and thank you for being here
um do you see the possibility of the two
changes one to expand this to not just
stem courses and the other to increase
the number from two to five being broken
into separate bills because although it
is possible for a student to take five
courses each year that would require a
student who would have a lot of time to
dedicate to the courses in addition to
being highly motivated which yes is
possible but I see as potentially
unlikely so do you see the potential for
this to be broken into two separate
bills
who would think of that more as a
legislative prerogative and decision if
it were broken into two bills and one
one were passed and the other not we
would work with with what the
legislature grants
thank you Mr President Cordell
appreciate it good morning and good
morning once again
um just a couple of structural things if
I make is there any cost for the high
school student at all
to take this to participating this
program
it's 150 dollars per course but if not
if they have these scholarships
available to them okay continue on that
line follow up yes yeah thank you so
um
the high schools let's make sure I'm
understanding the program the high
school offer course X currently in a
stem area X and seven kids registered
for that class you're using a high
school teacher in the high school
setting uh in the High School curriculum
with the sort of like an AP piece but
for Brian stock
can other students take that class with
that instructor with not wanting credit
not having to pay hundred dollars they
can yes okay
um and just one more make one more
follow-up
yeah great how many
um schools currently in the state
participate
all of them every Public School in New
Hampshire participates and then we have
many Charter Schools as well as private
schools well thank you that's true I
didn't know that thank you Mr
of Representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um I'm looking at the uh the Striking of
the requirement that these be um stem
and Career Tech
would you say that it is a a reasonable
concern that doing so
could shift the underlying
um utility of this program away from
students seeking more
um more rapid employment through either
careertech or associates degree programs
toward students looking more to fulfill
general education requirements and such
as Humanities and whatnot for a
four-year
degree program
yeah well that's a thought-provoking
question representing Belcher I think
it's certainly possible but I think
we're more likely to expand rather than
just shift I think that this opens up
opportunities the question posed earlier
about workload a student may be less
likely to take three or four stem
focused courses but might be more
interested in a balanced schedule of a
couple of stem focused courses and a
couple of humanities or or social
science courses so I think it's more
likely for the students pursuing this
challenge to expand and broaden as
opposed to just shift but I do
understand the concern I'll say that
internal to the organization one of the
challenges that we face is that the more
running Start program courses that we
delivered I should mention that only
about one in ten students who takes
running start comes directly to us over
the four or five year period we'll
probably see 20 percent of those
students but generally speaking these
two so taking the education elsewhere
but the more we do with running start in
the areas like math like English and
Humanities what it does is it
concentrates the curriculum left for us
to deliver in areas that are more more
stem more Health Care More frankly more
expensive to deliver it and so we are
cognizant of that shift internally but I
don't know that it changes the way
students use the program
if I could just follow up on that as
well I agree with the chancellor that
that's a great question and and one that
I've thought about as well but I think
when you're looking at five courses per
student per year that that's a lot of
courses at the college level so chances
are not a lot of students will have the
opportunity to take all five in that in
in one year I mean many students will
but it still will allow them to have
some stem some CTE and some gen Ed
courses so I I think it's it definitely
will allow that that five allows us to
kind of span all of the academic
credentials that students might need
when they're looking to go to college
and you know we had originally thought
about when when this program was first
introduced that we would fund all it
wouldn't be a limit to stem and CTE but
at that time funding wasn't available
you know very limited funding was
available plus the focus at that time
too was on stem very much very much on
stem so that's why we went with this
system and CTE due to lack of total
funding that we would have wanted to do
all courses
yes representative Balboni
thank you chair my question is again
requiring going back to the high school
requirements as well do you see these
courses replacing the ones that they're
already currently need to take for high
school because it seems to me just going
back from my daughter's experience in
high school that her schedule was
already really packed just taking the
courses that you needed to take and then
there were AP courses as well how would
these courses fit in
I think it's important to note that
these courses do exist in the high
school already so for example englishcon
every High School senior needs to take
Senior English so English comp is Senior
English so that many of the you know
whether it be psychology biology
whatever it might be the course exists
in the high school we just ramp it up if
you will and teach it as ask the high
school to teach it as a college course
specific to our requirements for a
college course so the high school
teacher is teaching our College syllabus
in that particular course for both high
school and college credit I just hello
yes I was just about to that so so who
determines if that student would be
ready to take that course would that be
the previous High School right we rarely
rely on the high school teachers and
school counselors to ensure that
students are ready for those courses all
right thank you
uh yes representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question so what's the basic difference
as I heard that between the AP courses
and the running start courses as is it
just the testing that um occurs with AP
courses also a great question and yes uh
for the most part the AP has its certain
requirements obviously in our college
courses have their certain requirements
if you're if you're talking about the
actual course content it's probably very
similar like an uh an AP History course
is probably very similar to one of our
history courses that we're teaching is
running start so very similar it's just
the testing with the AP they need to
pass the test for some colleges and get
a four on it with our dual credit
courses like such as running start then
that college credit is pretty much
transferable to any other college
without having to take a test so we do
see more students interested in taking
the running stock courses versus AP for
that reason
follow up yes
so I would assume that the the reason
the AP courses has have a test at the
end is to make sure of the quality of
the the final project and that the the
student actually qualifies for the
college credit
um has the Community College ever
considered having some sort of of
testing at the end of their uh running
start course to make sure that it it
actually the student is actually
achieving what they should for the
college the students are tested just
like they would be in one of our
colleges with the final exam and
obviously testing throughout the entire
course our College faculty work very
closely with the high school teachers
each running start teacher has a college
faculty partner who works with them
throughout the the semester to ensure
the rigor of the college courses being
upheld and actually will give the high
school teacher their tests their college
level tests to take if this the high
school teacher so chooses if they don't
want to use those tests then the the the
college faculty partner will review the
testing and all of the assessment
methods to ensure the rigor of that
college course is being upheld
foreign
any further questions from the committee
seen none thank you very much for your
testimony and story and maybe we could
get a card for you from for this bill as
well
and uh with that I'll close the hearing
on hb420
and we're just about on time for the
next bill which is HP 364 relative to
transportation for students attending
CTE centers
and uh
once again we will have uh the bill
introduced by
representative Ladd
Le
last year uh yesterday you know the
yesterday during the dialogue two
thousand dollars someone asked about
how people participate in that okay
that's my guess yeah we have no bills
available about today
such a story to stick with it
educated guess
at the end of the pyramids and all the
bills are passed on the failure your
local transfer statements
[Laughter]
right I've been aware of but I'll check
thank you
foreign
good morning again for 10 members of the
education committee for the record my
name is Rick Ladd I come from Haverhill
and today I'm here to introduce HB 364.
this is a bill relative to uh
transportation of students to and from
Career Technical education uh centers
and Deals primarily with the costs of
Transportation the process we we have
developed in the state here to reimburse
those sending schools for the cost of
running those as buses or transportation
that they use
so in looking at the sheet that I handed
you
and this is an older older sheet but it
it tells it sends the message that
um
how the transportation formula Works uh
we have allocated as we heard yesterday
nine million dollars each year for the
cost of tuition and transportation of
students to the Career Technical
Education Centers and when we do that
what we do with that nine million
dollars the first thing we do is we
subtract out of that nine million
dollars and pay the districts their
transportation costs
the transportation costs are based upon
the old formula we've had ever since I
can remember 10 cents per mile per pupil
if in fact the district does not provide
those transportation services then the
the board May approve thus transporting
a student in their own personal vehicle
at a cost of 25 cents per mile
that is done in some cases where we have
very few people riding the 60 some odd
passenger bus the yellow bus and it's
cheaper for them actually to drive
themselves at 25 cents per mile there's
also some students that are at the CTE
centers that following the close of
school on a given day they may have
employment right there by the CTE Center
so they can remain at the center
transport themselves to the workforce
job which they have that's in
association with a Career Tech
development program so there are some
students that do that but the majority
of our students now we and and the sheet
that you'll see here the CT student
population is running off the 9000. it's
a little higher than that now I'm going
to round it up to ten thousand but
when you look at that the number that
are transport is approximately 2 000
students a little less than that
because the remainder are already at the
center because that's where the high
school exists at that Center
so when we're looking at this
Transportation reimbursement let's look
at the formula that we have right now
the statutory language says we shall
reimburse districts the full cost of
Transportation full Transportation costs
was put in the legislation
can't remember if it was last year the
year before that but we just recently
did it when we knew that what they were
receiving was not enough however now
we're playing with the formula in terms
of so what is full Transportation costs
is that full in accordance with the
formula or is it full in terms of the
actual costs for transportation
it's if it's full in in regard to the
cost of transportation and the formula
is 10 cents per mile
if we were actually going to do this
properly we'd have to put another two
million dollars into that formula
instead of 2.6 million dollars six 680
000 approximately for transportation we
should be formulate our funding annually
2.6 million dollars
that is you know that's much more than
we can do because the remainder of the
money there you can see out of that nine
million dollars is used for tuition and
the more students that participate the
less tuition the students of the school
the sending District receives in terms
of the number of students that they're
sending of course we're splitting up a
limited pool of money for a growing
population and so the schools receive
less per child
when you compare our our system here in
New Hampshire to Delaware which is a
very similar uh location in terms of
number of of students you can see that
the state CTE funding for this state is
nine million dollars when you look at
Delaware it's 89 million dollars
per year
we are very much you know uh shorting
our our CTE centers in terms of getting
students to participate getting more
students to participate many districts
cannot send those students because
they're not getting the reimbursement or
the tuition Monies to send them to the
CTE program so a lot of those 10 000
students roughly 1 000 some odd number
of them come from the sending districts
that's that's a disservice to those
districts would send we have a number of
students which would love to take these
courses in terms of you know agriculture
diesel mechanics robotics Etc at the
center but they're not able to do so
seeing the district in order to do that
has to fund up that money themselves
without using this money right here it's
basically an unfunded program which
we're not going to you've totally fund
properly
so um what what we're proposing here if
you look at the sheet that I that I
stapled to this not the side where this
morning when I they went down that you
can see how bills are made like 188 cult
Dash e colon 8 you see how things been
scratched out and things are put in uh
that's not the side I'm looking at I'm
looking at a side that says Kansas
had an audit done of their
transportation system out there what
they were doing for CTE and they I'm
going to read part of it
um and to you here the to Aid the United
unified school districts in this
endeavor the legislative appropriated
funds for CTE Transportation Aid the
amount of which is based on a formerly
using type of vehicle
mileage and the number of trips made to
the college or to their location where
they get the CTE you can see it's not on
a per-pupal basis it's based on number
of trips the types of vehicles Etc used
for that we'd love to be able to you
know use a smaller vehicle a van to
transport a district of four or six K do
we do do we then fund them at the same
rate that we do the large yellow school
bus The Yards large yellow school bus
course uses more diesel it's more costly
to purchase
the school bus now we're talking what
about 175 000 I may be a little shallow
on that if it's electric it's four
hundred fifty thousand dollars
a van is much cheaper so its District
would rather use something like that
they can use it if they have it
available but it would also cost less to
run it if we did it by a new formula and
that's what this bill is proposing that
is proposing as they've done there you
can see they have categories Suburbans
and vans would get X number of dollars
per mile
um school bus so much and and school bus
another level based upon it's up based
on the formula now this bill doesn't get
into the development of the formula this
bill bill authorizes the Department of
Education to work this out to figure out
how are we going to set up our
transportation costs and reimbursement
to these school districts and it gives
them this by anyone to do that and once
that is established then we can flip
over to a new process
but we need to do something about this
right now it's unfair The Way It Is
We're limiting the number of students
which can participate in these centers
we did challenge the issue of calendars
which are we have some centers which
receive kids from nine different school
districts with nine negotiated contracts
for calendars Etc and getting them all
on the same page is like herding cats uh
it's it's it's just it can't be done
well what we've given them that we've
got to get not down to 10 non-conforming
forming days in your calendar total for
all those nine districts they're going
to work on this and that legislation was
just passed this last year and hopefully
that will eliminate kids not being able
to get over to the transfer to the CTE
Center but the biggest thing which we
got to address now is this
Transportation reimbursement and then we
got a tackle and another step in another
build this bill initially was going to
have tuition costs in there as well it I
decided to break this down so we can
tackle one thing at a time and then hit
the tuition costs at another time so
this can go includes in Nature's bill it
deals strictly with looking at a new
Transportation formula for the sending
districts to the receiving CTE Center
established by that would be established
by the Department of Education so thank
you very much I'd be glad to take any
questions thank you any questions for
representative Ladd representative
Belcher
thank you Mr Vice chair um
I definitely uh agree and I'm on board
with needing to sort this situation out
my one my one question is is there a way
to to guarantee in the rule making
process or to instruct them
to make sure that there's going to be a
measure of efficiency ultimately so we
don't wind up with a situation where
school districts are you know sending
one or two students long distances
perpetually on full-size school buses
and whatnot
if we're going I'll take my district
right now SAU 2023
and our CT Center is across the river in
Bradford Vermont and we're sending from
Litchfield high school so we're talking
maybe uh 30 to 40 minute ride depending
upon what's going on in the highways we
only have large buses
so that's what we're using up there the
smaller buses have been used for the
special education services which we have
um we we are a district which uh is very
involved with the CTE Center across the
river that's where the diesel mechanic
program is taught and and that is
critical to the agriculture Community
from which I come from
the the nature of the vehicle use is
something that would be worked out would
the department uh however we're not
going to put you must do it in a smaller
bus because there's there's another
funding issue which we're not funding uh
hopefully districts would get funded
based upon a certain
amount that's established in this bill
if it's going to be a larger bus you're
going to have to conform to what's going
to be set up by the the department on
that so I don't want to get in the
business saying you will transport on a
certain type of vehicle that's an
unfunded mandate
yep
yes representative Cornell
thank you I just want to make sure we we
changed it I think last session so that
Manchester got reimbursed
this doesn't impact that they'll still
get reimbursed yes and what
representative Cornell and thank you
representative Cornell for being on the
CTE committee and they have looked at it
and they're endorsing this what we had
going on in Manchester also uh was it
Nashua and extra you know it was three
districts that we had in statute that if
you're transporting within your District
boundaries you're sending to a dis
School in your District which is part of
your school district so they never
qualified because they weren't standing
outside the parameters of Manchester
we've changed that seeing that in
Manchester you might have your CTE on
the other side of town you could be
transporting kids five miles or so and
but they never received any
reimbursement whatsoever for that that
was changed so anytime you hop on a
school bus no matter where you are in
what district you will get reimbursement
at that 10 cents per mile
yeah representative miler thank you Mr
chair
so
364 basically is just directing
the department to create a new formula
is that correct there's no money
involved in this it's just a matter of
how to allocate that those funds in a
different process is that correct yeah
and we're trying to spell out we're
trying to get away from this per pupil
okay funding mechanism and looking at
the trying to reimburse for the the
costs of that bus moving uh you can't
move a bus at 10 cents per mile if you
only have four or five kids on it you're
gonna have a loss
representer
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
a lot of schools I think
um contract with bus services I know
when I coach tennis I would have like
maybe 12 girls and we'd get a big bus
and I think it would be so inefficient
um but they told me that that they
contracted per trip rather than you know
how many students or what was the most
efficient for them I guess that's that's
kind of their problem I'm just wondering
if this would interfere with
um those schools that actually contract
by the number of runs that are made and
the mileage that the this won't impact
that contractual basis at all what
you're going to do is get from the state
you're going to get X number of dollars
for the number of kids which were
transported on that particular bus if
you've agreed as a school district that
the contract is going to be based upon
runs
um then you're gonna have to pay that
but you're going to get reimbursed by
the you know the mileage you know per
mile per student that was transported on
that contracted service
any further questions
uh I have one representative lad if I
could in terms of the costs um the bill
takes effect in 2025 so
um we have until or the department and
the state board have until that time to
come up with a new formula but at that
point the new formula would kick in and
there would be possibly costs involved
for the state to provide the full cost
of Transportation related to that new
formula is is that correct that's
correct and what we're doing is we're
trying to put this off for several years
when we've looked at the cost of running
buses even for the rigor School District
daily operations trying to get this
information from doe has been very
difficult uh you have bus supervisors
and and and and people are familiar with
it some it to try to sort through the
doe 25 form and all that it's been
extremely difficult to find out what the
actual costs are and we've done this on
the CTE committee two years ago when we
were looking at the how the formula
works and it's a very convoluted formula
when you come to tuition
Transportation trying to get a handle
how much we're actually spending in all
and how it is also it's not as
complicated as a tuition formula which
is more more based upon the local makes
that decision between 20 and 40 percent
of the doe costs you know of the doe 25
per people cost and then there's a three
percent added on that for Capital uh
costs as well so it's a lot of this has
to be looked at I'm trying to go
incrementally here and work with Jeff
beard behind me here uh regarding uh
let's fix the transportation costs first
thank you any further questions so
representative Luna thanks very much Mr
chairman follow on to what what you just
asked with respect to the effective date
why wouldn't we accelerate this to uh
July 1st 2024. hey I'm all for it I'm
all for it what we also have I haven't
mentioned we have two other bills which
are coming down dealing with
um
Capital Capital Improvements for
building so no so let's let's just stay
here by this one yes I agree if the
timeline can be changed if we hear from
folks behind me well we could do this
earlier and and we should I'm all for
that yeah okay any further questions for
representative Ladd uh see none
um we do have someone from the
Department here if there are any uh
technical support questions
stop that anyone has for for the
Department
representative Lakers um Mr beard could
you come
and answer a question or two possibly
yes thank you so much uh great to see
everyone again two days in a row is a
rare and wonderful opportunity
um I'm available to answer any questions
representative representative would you
be able to get the rules done by 24
instead of 25 yes okay thank you you're
welcome
any further questions
uh you're getting off easy I think well
it's thank you to uh representative Vlad
who outlined it so uh so wonderfully in
with such detail um but thank you
everyone
thank you I see no further cards for
this bill so I will close the hearing on
how spill uh 364 and we have a few
minutes until
um the uh hearing for House Bill 267 at
11 30.
thank you
you guys kept asking questions
students
okay uh at this point in time I'm going
to open up the hearing for HB 267
relative to to criminal records checks
in school employment and recognize
representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair thank you members of
the committee for the record my name is
representative Joe Alexander I represent
the town of Goffstown I actually um
thank you for allowing me to testify at
education committee I have a former
Professor college professor on this
committee now so I hope she's very proud
of me testifying in this committee so HP
267 I believe is a simple piece of
legislation I put it I put in this bill
on behalf of the superintendent of the
Goffstown School District so he is here
to testify as well to provide clarifying
to answer questions if there are any I
believe it's a simple bill that would
merely enable a school administrative
unit or School District to require more
frequent
um
background checks or criminal record
checks this would apply to all employees
and volunteers not specific groups but
everybody that works in a school
district in the current statute only
requires one criminal history check upon
hiring and non-like none immediately
after or following so you can get a
situation where someone works for a
school district for 30 years and only
has one background check so this merely
would just enable during contract
negotiations more frequent background
checks but this is totally a local
control bill so it allows school
district and you know groups unions or
anybody to have those negotiations on
their own and local level so my ask is
that you support the bill and you know
my superintendent is here to give
specific situations where it might be
needed and so I'm happy to answer
questions but also defer to my
superintendent so thank you thank you
very much representative are there any
questions of Representative yes go ahead
and represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um do you know if is there any
requirement in law
um that the school or the or the
requesting agency pay for the background
check does it ever fall to the person
being checked
um it's my understanding that it's the
school district that pays for those
background checks but again that could
be part of those negotiations that
happen on the local level between the
school district and any groups thank you
yep
go ahead representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Alexander representative uh Alexander
for taking my question
um many people have background checks
for other aspects of their lives for
example uh coaching or something or
other other employment would you accept
a recent background check from another
source as to fulfill these obligations
so I think my superintendent can help
with this but I would say that
um that is all going to be a part of
that negotiation that happens on the
local level so they can have that
conversation about you know if you have
say they were they happen to agree to
requirement every 10 years and they
happen to have a more recent one for
some other position that could be part
of the language that's put into the
contract
further questions representative nyler
uh thank you Mr chairman and welcome and
thank you for being here you mentioned
local negotiations are you talking about
uh when they negotiate the the
collective bargaining agreement or I I
I'm not sure the reference when you use
the term negotiations that means one
thing to me I'm not sure what that means
to you
um it means the same thing to both of us
and um we have a specific situation that
happened that we're happy to talk about
and
um about local issues so yes thank you
you're correct
further questions
not seeing any thank you very much
uh just trying to get some information
here we have two cards here is there
anybody else that wants to speak on this
particular bill
okay uh yeah and um
he already has a card here
okay Brian thank you very much you're
welcome to come up
thank you chair good morning
you want to press excuse me the button
yeah
good morning thank you Mr chair my name
is Brian balke I'm the superintendent of
schools in Goffstown I've been the
superintendent for 10 years this is my
29th year in public education I'd like
to thank representative Alexander for
submitting this legislative Services
request
um on my behalf and I'd like to talk to
you about why I think this is important
and why I think this matters to the
state of New Hampshire and to local
school districts
so right now as Mr Alexander shared all
School staff are required to complete a
criminal records check that happens one
time
there are no requirements to have any
kind of an ongoing periodic check if
local school districts want to negotiate
that representative Miler asked about
negotiations I would confirm that that
means a collective bargaining agreement
with a union specifically in Goffstown
we have two unions we have a support
staff Union and we have a teachers union
they're both under Nea New Hampshire so
as we have negotiated contracts over the
many years one of the things that I have
wanted to focus on is having a local
policy and a local practice of having
represented having everyone have a
background checked with greater
frequency every three years we have to
recertify in this in the state of New
Hampshire as certified Educators we have
to submit evidence that we've continued
to perform professional development and
we've continued to hone our skills and
that's all part of the process what I
would like to do at the local level is
negotiate terms in our Union contracts
that would allow us to do criminal
records checks on that same frequency
right now the statute is silent does not
allow us to do that and we're looking
for enabling language that I can point
to and say the statute specifically says
local school districts can create
different frequencies of criminal
records checks based on their own local
contracts we already have that in a
school board policy through the
Goffstown school board but we'd like to
codify that in our negotiated contracts
as well if I can and I'm happy to answer
any questions as I go but I have some
more information to share if I may so
what I'd like to propose is I'd like to
give a little bit of history on this so
This statute was first enacted in 1993
and in 2000 there were some pretty big
changes that Restricted Section 5
violations so specifically in 2000 that
included murder child pornography
aggravated felonious sexual assault
felonious sexual assault and kidnapping
those are the only things that we
screened for beginning in 2000 so if you
had any other convictions minor
convictions or more significant
convictions I would say arson should be
on that list it's not so you could be
convicted of arson and you could be a
certified teacher in the state of New
Hampshire and as a superintendent I
potentially have no recourse no ability
to check your background again
so what we have is we have situations
that in 1993 I still have 17 employees
that are employed in SAU 19 and the
communities of Goffstown and New Boston
that were never given a criminal records
check at any point in time they were
hired prior to the statute even being
enacted
so pre-2000 I have 47 employees that
were hired before before uh 2000. I have
no idea if they have any convictions
Beyond those five felonies that we
listed and in 2017 the statute changed
that went through this committee and
what superintendents now receive is a
more comprehensive background check it
includes arrests it includes
misdemeanors and that allows us at the
local decision to evaluate child safety
and make decisions at the local level
this is not a gotcha this is not I'm out
to to catch people who have a unsavory
things in their past this is about
making sure that children are safe and
in Goffstown if we want to negotiate
terms that we're going to do criminal
records checks every three years we need
a statute that allows us to do that
that's why this was brought before you
so the other thing I would share in 2018
the code of ethics and code of conduct
was put into place you're probably all
familiar with this and if you look at
page 11. page 11 says that
unprofessional conduct shall include and
it says failure to self-report within
five business days if he or she meaning
a teacher a credentialed educator has
been arrested for any violations of
offenses enumerated in RSA 189 13a5
which are those list of felonies the
list was expanded and it now includes
things like prostitution endangering the
welfare of a child in decent exposure
lewdness possession of child sex images
distribution of child sex images
manufacturing of child sex images use of
computers for child sex images obscene
matters and material capital murder
first degree murder second degree murder
manslaughter aggravated felonia sexual
assault felonious sexual assault sexual
assault kidnapping human trafficking and
incest anything else that anyone would
be arrested for or convicted for they
have no obligation to even tell me as
the employer according to the code of
ethics
now I think this document is wrong but
this isn't my purview so what I want to
do is negotiate terms at the local level
this is fully supported by our school
board in Goffstown to be able to have
language in the statute that would allow
us to negotiate these terms as we said I
would say that unfortunately there seems
to be an uptick in the number of
Educators who are engaging in
inappropriate behavior and I would share
that on the New Hampshire New Hampshire
education department website there's a
technical advisory and press releases
that indicate the number of educator
misconduct investigations are increasing
the department reported in 2014 there
are 170 investigations and the last
number they shared was 2018 with well
over 200 I don't know what that number
is now attorney Fenton is here from the
Department she could probably speak to
that there's a list right now of over
200 Educators in the state of New
Hampshire who have had their license to
teach suspended or revoked
200.
who knows what they
were background checked on or when
so again we're looking to have local
terms that we can negotiate I will share
I've had two examples that the committee
might be interested in we had a long
time teacher that worked for us this
individual left the profession of
education at a later point in time chose
to go back into teaching I get a call
from the Department of Ed that there was
a question about their background
another school district went to hire
this individual and did not because of
their background I have no idea what it
was I have no idea what their
convictions were I have no idea what
they found in that background all I know
is as a sitting teacher in my school
district I didn't have that information
and that was important to me so at the
end of the day this is fundamentally all
about local control and making sure that
we're doing everything in our due
diligence to make sure kids are safe and
respectfully I would ask you to support
this proposed Bill and I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you are there
any questions
representative cordelli uh thank you
thank you for being here and um and
testifying on this uh and I'm not sure
if I heard you correctly but it seemed
like you were indicating that you wanted
to be able to
include in your contract negotiations
scheduled correct background checks but
also possibly
additional offenses that you might be
looking for beyond the section five
offenses did I hear you correctly or
misunderstand correct
to follow up yes so so you want to be
able to negotiate
um would you put that into a contract
negotiations what offenses you would be
looking for as part of the criminal
records check or would just be the
schedule
um I would imagine again that would be
part of the negotiations with our um
with our unions but I would think it
would be the frequency cycle that the
background checks would be done and then
probably some logistical parameters
around once that the first batch has
been rechecked that then a future
superintendent wouldn't have the ability
to come back and
um basically
reconsider something that had already
been accepted and approved by the
sitting superintendent so that's the
kind of language that I think we would
negotiate the statute also specifically
says at the local level school boards
can develop their own local policies
that include the types of offenses
including misdemeanors or other things
that might be restricted for employment
but I want to be clear with committee
this is not about me finding people
who've done bad things this is just
about making sure that we're keeping
kids as safe as we can and it's
surprising to me that Educators don't
already have to do this I think if you
ask most parents do you think your kid's
teacher gets a background check every
once in a while I think most people
would say well they must right
how often do doctors get background
checks
do they get done once and then never
again
I don't know
further questions represent miler
and thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here and bringing this to our
attention
there's no question I'm sure that every
member of this committee wants to make
sure that we have teachers that are safe
and meet the the appropriate uh behavior
that for them to work with kids I've got
a couple questions for you though
um isn't there currently in a collective
bargaining agreement uh grounds for
dismissal
uh that would be covered in a background
check for example that's the first
question
um I might defer to attorney Fenton on
that I would say not that I'm aware of
so in our in our negotiated Union
contracts there are Provisions that
allow us to dismiss a teacher but it's
basically predicated on three tenants in
subordination incompetence or immorality
arguably the immorality piece you could
consider but if we don't have any
knowledge that someone has been arrested
or convicted of a crime we wouldn't have
any ability to even have that
information to pursue a potential
disciplinary measure with an employee
thank you second question is what's the
current charge for a background check I
think it's thirty dollars and what we I
think representative Alexander said that
he thinks that would be part of the
negotiation I would agree I can tell you
that we already included money in our
budget to do the increased number of
background checks but volunteers per
statute are supposed to pay themselves
and then local school districts can have
a policy that reimburses them if they
decide to so in your school district
you're in the follow-up questions your
your intent then uh would be to pay for
them yes yes thank you very much yes
thank you I have a question for you uh
have you talked with other
administrators in other districts
whether they're seeing a similar concern
as as you or talk with I see Jerry fruit
hiding behind Brian back there
um
I I have in fact spoken with Jerry frew
I've spoken with other superintendents I
think this is an example of something of
I don't know why I'm the only one here
wanting to fix this this seems to me
this should be something that everyone
who works in public education should
know about and care about you're not
compelling anyone to do anything you're
just allowing local school districts to
negotiate terms I can tell you that in
those negotiations
um with Nea and I'm not speaking ill of
Nea in any way but when I've brought up
criminal record checks in an increased
frequency I have been met with there is
nothing in the statute that allows you
to do that
which arguably is true
further questions yes representative Dan
Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so you indicated that the Goffstown
school board has a policy to do this
correct
and I understand that the law there
isn't a law
that says you may do this but is there a
law that says you can't
there is not a law that says you can't
and specifically I would
um show you it's Goffstown School Board
policy g b c d and
gbcd-r which is the regulation so we do
have language that allows us to do the
criminal record check with greater
frequency however there's nothing
um nothing that would allow me to do
that in our contract so even though it
says it in policy it would be considered
a change in working conditions it would
be grieved and I would lose any kind of
a grievance Appeal on that topic so just
having it in stat in your policy is not
enough
thank you further questions
representative Hall
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my location
um I just want to be clear on the intent
of the bill is the intent to be able to
do the background checks or the intent
truly to be able to negotiate that it's
to negotiate so the the language that um
representative Alexander submitted in
the LSR is exclusively allowing the
ability to negotiate at the local level
I think the majority of our school
districts all have Union contracts so
every school district would have to
negotiate specific terms with their
unions as part of their agreement I just
want the ability to do that this is
important to me it's important to my
school board we think teachers and
anyone working with kids should have
background checks on a reoccurring
systematic predictable basis you're
going to work with kids this is part of
it we need to make sure I want to say
that I believe my employees haven't done
anything that I would have issue with
but I would say as Ronald Reagan said
trust but verify
um you all you also mentioned
thank you by the way for taking my
question but you also mentioned
um what you wanted the background check
of and my understanding in many years
talking with the Department of Safety
is that they can all they are only
checking for the education department
those things in the list which as you
said we expanded a number of times
um you know from the original five
um
how would that work with the Department
of Safety was doing the background
checks if they are if currently we've
said in Statue these are the things
we're checking on and these are the
things that they check on because that's
what's in Statue statute and I don't see
that in this bill at all sure So
currently right now uh we don't just
check the section 5 violations right now
current superintendents for any employee
any volunteer who gets a background
check we get their entire
um history so we get any arrests any
convictions any Court proceedings and
that includes misdemeanors as well as
the section five felony violations so I
don't see that it would be a change in
practice for the State Police or their
Partners at the FBI it would however
likely be an increased volume so I would
certainly acknowledge that for the State
Police there could be an increase in
volume but I would say
good this is keeping Kids Safe
thank you represent cascadden
thank you Mr chair and thank you Brian
for bringing this forward I'm looking at
just the the language of the Bell it's
as relative to criminal records uh
record checks in school employment and I
just question if you I don't know if you
can answer this but when I look at
school employment are we talking only
about the current employees are we
talking about the teachers or who are in
a school employment of a private school
or a non-public school so yeah this
would include any employees designated
volunteers or any contracted services so
for example you've likely heard that for
many of the positions that we have needs
for like speech and language
Pathologists as an example many of us
are not able to hire those folks as
employees and we have contracted service
agreements only when we can't find
people and those individuals would also
be subject to the criminal records
checks just a follow-up yes
um so I just wonder then
um education Freedom account has a list
of service providers and wondering if
this would apply to all those service
providers
under the education Freedom accounts as
well as the retailers that are service
providers I don't believe that there
would be any applicability for that I
might defer to the department if
attorney Fenton thinks that might be the
case but essentially this would just
allow us so any employee that would be
covered under the criminal records check
I would need to negotiate the terms with
our partners at Nea to have language
that would be acceptable to both of us
to do those criminal records checks if
someone is not covered by a collective
bargaining agreement then we would have
the ability to require that increased
frequency and by the way I would share
this would include any credentialed
licensed
teacher educator including the
superintendent
my community should know that I haven't
had anything in my criminal background
that they should be aware of I've been
there 15 years I'm I predate some of
these statutes they have not done a
criminal records check on me again
thank you representative woodcock
thank you chairman I appreciate it good
morning super time good to see you a
couple questions is the um Secondary
School administrators Association
supporting this
um the New Hampshire School
administratives Association I believe
signed the clipboard that they were in
support of this and doe
um I don't want to speak for the
Department attorney Fenton is here I
don't know if she has the ability to
answer that on behalf of the department
I have however I will share with the
committee I've spoken with Diana Diana
and I have worked on this
um I've been talking to her about this
for a number of years and we were
finally able to work with representative
Alexander to bring this before you and
the final part of my singular question
uh on line 20 uh uh the new language in
this uh requested a change I just want
to be clear this is on any group of
employees so once you set up your cycle
uh if you did teachers today you could
not do teacher X next year
because you did it today is that correct
um again I think that would depend upon
specifically what we negotiated but that
would be the intent and I I do want to
be clear this is not about singling
anyone out it's not about I line
teachers up and I I want to do a
background check on you and you and you
this is about everybody all together so
I understand that but but I want I just
want to be clear if perhaps
representative ladder someone else can
interpret this for me but I can I'm
looking at line 20 and it just as it
says on any group of employees so I'm
just that would preclude you from doing
employee X
correct unless you do all employee X is
correct that that was the intent okay
thank you thank you chairman thank you
uh I'm gonna stop with the questions
right here on this one and ask
prosecutor Fenton
um
well we can Elevate you the colonel or
general if you'd like that
with a chair like me to leave or are
there any more are there any more
questions of the superintendent
statistics
uh let's you know if you just sit down
and then we'll bring you back forward
words and you can get the one question
here and let's try to get some technical
support here
good morning for the record my name is
Diana Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education most of the
statutory changes that were mentioned as
it pertains to RSA 18913a
um we're spearheaded uh by myself at the
department with the understanding that
when I was transferred over from the
Attorney General's office to the
Department of Education now the
department was really lacking in child
safety initiatives so I'm happy to give
this committee a brief overview of
um the changes that have occurred in 189
13A and to answer some of the questions
that were raised however you'd like me
to proceed
are there any questions for our
representative yes representative Luna
thank you very much thank you very much
Mr chair thank you very much Jennifer
for joining us um and maybe you can do
this you know while you're um uh while
you're sort of laying the ground
groundwork uh for this but but
um you know over the over the past
session I think we dealt with a number
of bills that um that made changes to
criminal background checks and I think
one of the one of the most interesting
ones
was some House Bill 1398
um Prime sponsor was representative
Carol McGuire uh which uh which actually
um
um establishes a study committee
commission committee to um to examine
the feasibility of the department
um uh centralizing uh criminal records
check and I knew there were there were
there was certainly a lot of um
you know concern confusion how to manage
that at a local level how to manage that
with between
um multiple districts that may be part
of an SAU or people that work across
different districts or something like
that
um and then um I what what the
superintendent brought up was the um the
uh the three-year recertification
process and and I guess I'm wondering
about your thoughts on how maybe uh uh
something like that like this
um a periodic
um
check uh might be uh might be something
that gets incorporated into the the
study uh of you know when household 1398
um uh is taken up and uh has I think the
report due date is November of this year
so this is something that's currently I
think active
um in terms of uh how do we really go
about providing comprehensive criminal
background checks in a way that's uh
that's meaningful and useful to um to
school districts and the people that
they serve
yes so thank you for the question
um I'm going to answer your question in
somewhat of a long historical approach
so bear with me the statute in front of
you 189 13A and the proposed Bill 189
13A deals exclusively with employment
and you have to keep those two different
tracks in mind there's employment and
then there's the licensing process at
the Department of Education and those
are two separate entities so the statute
in front of you and the bill in front of
you again 189 13A is employment based so
if I were an educator and I went to
representative cascad in the former
district and applied for a job in her
old role as superintendent she would do
a background check on me and determine
if I was a good fit for her District
historically prior to 2015 when that
background check for employment was
conducted
the records would go to the Department
of Safety you will see a gentleman in
green sitting behind me anytime this
committee deals with background checks
anything with 189 13 a b or c you will
see state police come and join us
because our world suddenly collide the
Department of Education is not in charge
of criminal records criminal records are
governed by the by the FBI and there are
federal regulations in place because of
that so
with employment prior to 2015 and again
I'm going to pick on representative
cascaden in her formal role as a
superintendent those those criminal
records for me for employment purposes
would be sent to the Department of
Safety
they would look at my record and they
would determine based on the statute
looking at at Roman numeral five which
sets out those disqualifying offenses
that were mentioned they would look at
my record and they would say does Miss
Fenton have any of this these
disqualifying offenses this is what you
mentioned and then they would write a
letter
to the to the school district and they
would say Miss Fenton either does have a
disqualifying offense pursuant to
section five and therefore cannot be
hired
right no discretion on the
superintendent or she does not have such
an offense and you can hire her if you
so wish but it was kind of The Man
Behind the Green curtain no one knew if
there were other offenses
right or what those offenses were
it was what I called I called it the red
light green light letter
because it had no detail it simply said
yes the person has an offense and you
can't hire them or they don't have one
of those disqualifiers and you can hire
them here's what happened with that
system
there was an educator who was charged
with a very serious sexual assaults uh
aggravated felonious sexual assaults in
Sullivan County
for whatever reason those charges were
reduced to misdemeanor level offenses
they were not Section 5 offenses they
were still serious there was still
something superintendents wanted and
should have known about as it pertains
to child safety but when the department
of safety ran that individual's record
when he applied for another job in
another District
the person running the record said
these are troubling but they're not
Section 5 offenses and so the letter
simply stated this individual does not
have any of these offenses the
superintendent hired that person and he
reoffended
that really kicked off
the changes that were mentioned prior to
2000 and after 2015 we saw a flurry of
legislative activity in
2016-2017-2018 and it was because of
that incident you know in essence we
wanted to provide more information to
superintendents so they could make an
informed decision
and that's why when you look at 189 13A
misdemeanors and felonies the entire
record of offenses is being released to
superintendents and they have the
discretion within section five to say
the disqualifiers I don't have any any
discussion with that those are across
the board no discretion I cannot hire if
someone has one of those offenses but
there are a lot of other offenses that
they can take into consideration I think
a great one is DWI right they can look
to see is that someone that I want in in
my district arson was mentioned we have
certified Educators who have arson on
their record
and they are employed in various
districts
um what is lacking from the section 5
violations that I find interesting no
drug offenses
no drug offenses last session we uh did
put a bill through that was passed that
uh prohibited someone who had a felony
level uh drug conviction of possession
with intent to distribute it had to be
felony level it had to be within the
last 10 years and that law becomes
effective January 1st so that has just
started
that it's just as started but prior to
that no drug offenses
so that's all employment based the
superintendent has an enormous amount of
discretion to look at that record in its
entirety and decide is this the right
fit for my district
putting that aside for a minute let's
talk about the parallel track
the Department of Education realized
that the Department issues the
credential to teach and because of that
we have a child safety obligation as
well
so we beca we came before this
legislative body as a state agency and
asked for statutory permission
to run a criminal records check on
individuals before we license them to
teach and you will find that in 189 13c
it's named 189 13c for credentialing
that's how I remember it anyway and I'll
give you a tip 18913b that's for bus
driver B for bus driver it's the only
way my brain works so
it was done for a reason that way I
promise you so 189 13c was created as a
parallel track to employment
to give the department the authority to
start to run records checks for
first-time educator applicants so that
can be someone right out of Keene State
or it could be someone transferring in
from a different state
right who has been an educator in
Massachusetts for 20 years but they're
new to New Hampshire
the difference between the two checks is
that the department is limited only to
those Section 5 violations only to those
disqualifiers the reason being is as a
state agency we do not want to license
someone who is unemployable
that was the whole thought behind it we
don't want to license someone allow them
that certificate that license uh when
they can't be employed in a school
district we felt that as a state agency
that didn't support the field
and that wasn't helpful for child safety
and so those are the two parallel tracks
that have been created if you think
about it in this sense the department is
the floor of protection right we're just
going to screen for those Section 5
violations to say is this person
employable
the districts have much more discretion
to say
yes this person is employable but
perhaps they're not the right fit for my
district so I go back to that DWI
example
the the department will license someone
to teach who has a DWI on their record
maybe two DWIs why because it is not a
disqualifying offense
it's not
but a district can take that information
into account when making a hiring
decision
so getting back on my long-winded tour
to representative Luna's question the
study commission that was created the
idea behind it was to say what other
function can the Department of Education
serve can it serve as a record
Clearinghouse as it does for bus drivers
for showing 189 13B right is there
another function the department can play
um
I have not yet attended one of those
meetings I think it is a great idea I
the department requested representative
McGuire to bring that bill forward
because this area needs to be explored
it certainly uh has a lot of potential
my only caveat is to recognize that this
is a new role that the department is
playing
the department is just now really
building the infrastructure for running
record checks on first-time educator
applicants and we need time to be able
to work out all the the issues that will
inevitably arise but we have put our
plan into place and we are starting to
roll that out we're very excited about
this new initiative and working with our
partners in the field and strengthening
child safety but I just always ask I've
tested if I did this before that we're
not given too much too soon
because if we have a crack in the system
it's going to impact child safety and
that we can't do so I appreciate your
question thank you for listening to my
long-winded answer and I'm happy to take
any additional questions representative
Fenton I'd like to follow up to what uh
representative was addressing with Carol
McGuire's sure bill
that would if something's done through
Carol McGuire's bill it's going to be
done across the board for all districts
as far as looking at changes maybe
within all all the languages stats we
were talking about is there are we
opening up a real crack when we're
allowing District a now to go ahead and
make as what Brian's requesting right
now do a criminal check of an employee
whenever
and then that person is not hireable
there or is not going to be there and
they go next door to the abutting
districts oh yeah we're going to hire
this individual because we don't have
the criminal background check are we
going to have some conflicts between
districts if we don't do something like
this on a Statewide basis instead of
letting it be a negotiated issue for
every District in this state which is
going to be
difficult to be consistent with
you know potentially I will I will
clarify a couple of things first and
foremost I'm not a representative I just
need to correct the record on that one
representative LED right you are a
general I know those you're very
generous in your titles
um and I don't think the bill allows for
a check whenever the bill I think is
very well structured to allow for it to
be negotiated at the local level
um I can tell you anecdotally that when
I started at the department in 2015 I
had a superintendent take me aside at a
conference and say can I run a records
check on a more frequent basis
um and so this has been something that's
been kind of percolating for a while and
when I would speak to Brian about it the
decision was made it's something the
department was interested in bringing
forward but we recognized it wasn't a
department bill
it's a local level Bill and so we
decided to step back I was happy to work
with Brian and answer any questions he
had but this is an employment issue the
department doesn't deal with employment
this is employment only and I think you
have to trust the field to
take this task on and if one district is
doing it
um I think the other districts will will
engage in it as well so I don't think
that the vision that you envision will
occur I could be wrong but I think that
you'll find that every District that
I've worked with every superintendent
I've spoken to this is their top
priority
this is a tool that will enable them to
do this and I would be surprised if if
they didn't all take take advantage of
it
um but again that's just my my
perception of it thank you
representative Tanner
thank you I don't want you to get away
without a question I I would be remiss
if I did so and and this is kind of um a
setup question but perfect how frequent
would you recommend or do you think
background checks should be done in
order to minimize the risk
at a school
well thank you for the question I'm
going to take this opportunity to
address another question that was raised
about if someone had been checked
previously or recently can that record
be kind of transferred over or relied
upon
um the short answer to that question is
is no it cannot for a variety of reasons
first and foremost you always want to be
careful of stale records and that is a
term of art when you start working in
criminal records which representative
Tanner is very familiar with recognizing
that today you run my criminal record
it's clean
and tomorrow it could change because
tonight I'm going to go out and rob a
bank or something like that so that's
always the anecdotal story that you will
hear from State Police
um in terms of the stale record piece
the other thing to rec recognize and
remember with criminal records is now
we're dealing with federal regulations
and the FBI
and they will oversee the dissemination
of this record so this bill I will take
the wind out of state police of sale
this bill will have to be vetted by the
FBI before it's enacted
it can be passed by this legislative
body and become law but it will not be
acted upon until the FBI and the federal
government say yes we approve it and we
have had to deal with that hurdle in all
the bills that have come before this
legislative committee as it pertains to
189 13 a c and and B B and C there we go
um
so that's an additional hurdle to to
recognize the FBI prohibits me from
getting a record and handing it over to
another District it violates their
regulations
um your question how often do I think it
really doesn't matter what I think
personally
um I think the the three-year cycle
basing it on the renewals
makes logical sense
but I think the strength of this bill
before this committee is it defers to
local control
and it allows them to work that out and
negotiate it as to what works for that
particular District I can tell you right
now the department does not do an
additional criminal records check upon
renewal we don't we don't have any plans
to do that
we only do it for that first time
educator applicant whether that's right
out of college or someone coming into to
this state
yes
so
um I taught for 35 years long time ago
when the dinosaurs roamed on the land
and every three years I had to get a
background check when I renewed my
license I'm I'm wondering when the
Department of Education stopped doing
that
I'm you know I believe
um I think
there's I think we used to do them until
the 90s
maybe 95 96
and then we stopped that practice for a
significant amount of time
and now we're we're doing that again and
we certainly are open to the discussion
of doing those criminal histories upon
renewal
I would hope that that's part of that
study commission idea
um that was mentioned but right now we
are just rolling out the
um infrastructure for doing those
first-time educator applicants
representative cascaden and
representative Miler anybody on this
side
okay thank you Mr chair and thanks Diana
for all that work anything we could do
any of us um to increase child safety is
definitely most valuable and I just go
back again to the question that that I
asked the superintendent in this Essence
the department has a list of service
providers paid for and funded by efas
including retailers and so my question
is if those
non-public entities whether they're
retailers or private service providers
it would seem to me that we would be
offering the same or requiring the same
as someone who's graduating from college
and you're doing a criminal background
check before they're employed and I
suspect there is a vetting process for
them these entities to be on the master
list of service providers and just would
see that if it might create more buy-in
in public schools
if everyone who is servicing a child has
that same criteria so do you know if
that's in the works or my understanding
is that is part of the EFA program I can
get you more details as it pertains
appreciate that thank you happy to do
that thank you
representative uh thank you Mr chair you
referred to a 189 13A BC you've got
something in front of you what are you
referring to
my lava okay that's not the new one is
it no my new one's at home and in my
office so I have I carry this in my car
because I'm a legal dork the the only
reason why I raise this is that that the
new one is not the book that we have as
a committee
we have not received the new book yet
so for new members of the committee they
don't have the yellow book nor the new
book
and we need to know why we can't get
those books okay that's really not
that's less that's a rhetorical
rhetorical question I we talked about
that this morning and we're on it uh I
don't think we want to tie up
attorney Fenton on that one right now
you go to my car and uh take this out of
the trunk if you'd like I'll look the
other way uh my understanding is
representative cordelli's is working on
that issue it falls outside of my
purview but as I've said to
representative Tanner I understand her
uh desire for the book because I love
them as well so
and you got that book from me
I'm getting myself and all sorts of
trouble here let's let's go on here to
representative woodcock
well in the book we don't have attorney
I'm looking at uh thank you for taking
this I appreciate it okay all right uh
I'm looking at the same question I asked
this of a tenant uh on
specifically line 20 of the new language
that talks about uh the doing the record
check he was talking about on on a cycle
um for any group I just want to be clear
that
um your interpretation of this language
is similar to his and that an individual
employee who is already employed could
not be required to get an additional
background check at some point until
it's the cycle of his group this is that
that's my question yeah thank you for
your question and when you brought that
up I remember looking at this language
um
I know that one of our concerned shared
concerns when Brian and I met to work on
this language was
the opportunity to misuse this tool
because this really is a is this is a
tool for school districts
um and I know that he and I had this
discussion at length that we didn't want
anyone to be able to come in and use it
in a vindictive way to Target an
individual to say I'm going to go after
this person and I think that's why we
put that language's language in I don't
know if it was my suggestion or Brian's
or a combination of the two but we
recognize that this is really as I
mentioned a strong tool for for school
districts and superintendents they have
needed this for a long long time what we
don't want to have happen is it for it
to be misused for a vindictive purpose
um and if I may just very quickly
piggyback on representative belcher's
question
using the book you don't have in front
of you
um one 189 13A addresses your question
Roman numeral
four that says that the schools may
require the selected applicant for
employment or designated volunteer to
pay the actual cost of the criminal
history records check
most districts for employment purposes
absorb that cost it is part of
employment for volunteers that cost
typically falls on the on the volunteer
so I hope that answers your question and
you're welcome to use my book to
validate it okay thank you uh Diana
Fenton
um you referenced that we could pass
this as a state but then we're gonna
have to deal with the FBI
you're going to have to deal with the
FBI either way is is similar language or
this process
already
in effect in other states we're a very
small state here in this country is
similar language being applied dealing
with employees elsewhere like a Maine or
Vermont or Nebraska
that's an excellent question I
appreciate it I don't know as it
pertains to employment
how other states handle it I am more on
the licensing credentialing end of it
um
I can tell you anecdotally that as a
nation and I go to annual conferences on
this particular issue from the licensing
piece we recognize that we are in such a
movable Society people go across the
border so easily and so across the board
we are really upping our child safety
initiatives because we've had these
issues uh happen where one person leaves
and pick on Virginia and they go to New
Hampshire and they miss that there's
been this criminal activity or what have
you
um so I'm happy to look into it
employment wise
as to what other states are doing again
we've really focused on that licensure
piece so I don't know off the top of my
head the answer could you please do a
little checking around for it absolutely
thank you
other questions for the DOE
yes represent Cornell
thank you I don't know if I heard you
write attorney Fenton when you were
answering rep cascad and did you say
that efas you think are requiring these
kind of checks every three years already
I'm not sure about the every three years
I know that the background check is part
of the EFA program and I will get you
more details as it pertains to that
thank you for the further questions
thank you very much thank you
okay do we have any more pink cards up
here not seeing any we're going to close
this hearing
thank you lunch
you want to talk back yeah one o'clock
foreign
and start this meeting we finished our
last hearing a little bit late so some
members are will be coming in uh we're
about seven minutes late on this one
already so I'd like to open this hearing
for HB 377 this is relative to screening
and intervention in public schools for
dyslexia and Related Disorders represent
qatab
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and to the
committee for having me here today I'm
representative Caitlin kutab I represent
Rockingham District 17 Windham
I'm here today to introduce House Bill
377 House Bill 377 changes the literacy
screening requirements for dyslexia in
our public schools from Once in
kindergarten or first grade and at
appropriate times thereafter to twice
yearly in grades K to two and it also
clarifies the intervention timeline
this bill is crucial for ensuring that
the children in our state have the
opportunity to develop strong literacy
skills and succeed in school and in life
literacy is the foundation upon which
all learning is built and it is crucial
that we identify and address any
literacy difficulties as early as
possible
being at grade level before third grade
is imperative because prior to third
grade student students are learning to
read
from third grade on they're reading to
learn
my kindergartner had this screening in
October and has been receiving
intervention in a month he went from
identifying nine capital letter sounds
to 20 capital letter sounds doubling his
recognition in what he learned in three
months without any intervention
most of the children receiving special
education in the specific learning
disability category are dyslexic that's
about 10 000 kids in the state of New
Hampshire or one in three of the state's
special education
when it's caught early it likely makes
the difference of only needing
intervention and not special education
this not only considerably saves money
but also significantly increases the
likelihood of the child's academic and
emotional success
you may be wondering why it's needed
twice a year through second grade and
that's because this is a screening tool
it's not diagnostic so some children may
be missed the first time so it's
important that we monitor their progress
some kids may be doing okay at the
beginning of the year because their
skills match the expected performance at
that time in that grade but then as the
bar gets raised their skills may not
continue to develop with their peers and
so if the screening is repeated it can
help to determine if their skills have
increased according to the higher
expectations or not
the Department of Education assessment
data from last year shows that 55
percent of children Statewide cannot
read at grade level in New Hampshire our
children deserve better this is an easy
screening which only takes 10 minutes or
less and there are free tools available
to do it I urge you to support this bill
for the future of our children by
ensuring that they have the literacy
skills that they need to succeed thank
you for your time and consideration
thank you very much are you willing to
take any questions happy to are there
questions from the committee represent
cordinelli uh thank you thank you for
being here and bringing this forward
um I was wondering if if you might know
um or maybe someone else who is later
testifying might know but the existing
statute specifies the Dibbles
um screening tool and I heard something
yesterday that um maybe
um they had been bought by another
company or the name had changed or
something like that
um you know it's one of the dangers of
putting a specific product name in a
statute
um so if anyone knows it's something
maybe we could correct via a simple
Amendment
um as part of this process sure so I did
check last night and there is still a
free version of of the Dibbles tool
available online so
um it does specify in the Bell or an
equivalent evidence-based screener so if
that didn't become the choice I'm happy
to amend it but if that didn't become
the choice of the the school district
they do have the leeway to use any
evidence-based screening tool that they
want to use
thank you
further questions from the committee
yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative kutab
um line
10 it says in kindergarten or line 10 to
11 it says in kindergarten through
second the initial screening shall be
completed no later than 60 days of a
student entering Public School in
kindergarten through second grade what
if say for example you had a homeschool
student who came in in third fourth
fifth grade and maybe they had learning
issues would they be allowed to be
tested for dyslexia
sure so this is a screening that would
be for the entire population of the
school and so for everybody they'd be
getting at K to two if somebody entered
later after and the school found an
issue then absolutely I would agree that
they should screen them at that point
and I would but it may be repetitive at
that point to keep re-screening all of
the children of the school rather than
just you know new children
further questions yes represent dry
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative
um
I'm looking at the the second paragraph
which is all italicized which talks
about what happens if a screening takes
place and there's some method of
intervention required I just wonder if
does that not automatically kick in you
have do you have to specify how this
goes
yeah so currently it's at the discretion
of the school district
um we did have in the original bill it
said that they needed to provide
something by January 1st of the school
year
um however
it didn't say some some schools were
taking this kind of wait and see
approach rather than
if they thought it was invalid re
rescreening the child or
if it was even more severe referring
them to special education so that the
point was not to make these kids wait
all of this time to receive the help
that they may need
I have a question for you is it wise to
put like a 30 days and then what happens
if it's just before Christmas break are
these 30 school days are these 30 days
calendar days uh
hi you know is it wise to put a timeline
like that due to the fact there are a
number of variables in calendars from
District to District
so
even with school break with Christmas
break kind of one of our longest breaks
I believe that would still equate to
allowing for our 15 plus school days for
that to be completed so
um
I'd be okay changing it to a smaller
number and saying school days but I
wouldn't want it to necessarily be
30 school days that's that's really a
long period when there's only 180 days
in the school year we're talking
um
that's 1 8 of the whole school year
okay thank you for the question
representative Cascade thank you Mr
chair and thank you for the bill I just
questioned do you know that there are
that many school districts without
either a reading Specialist or Title One
program that it warrants additional
criteria for that to occur I mean my
experience
is that it happens based on individual
need not at any particular time
um so are you thinking reading
Specialists are not doing this or Title
One programs are not addressing the
needs of individual students or so not
every district is doing this no and
sometimes what will happen is as a kiddo
will get intervention in kindergarten
and then they'll catch up back to grade
level they'll stop receiving services or
intervention and then
they're behind Again by the end of first
grade and we're not catching it because
we're not re-screening them
I'm sorry about that
yes represent McDonald thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking the
question this says it's for dyslexia and
Related Disorders could you touch on
what those Related Disorders include
so I could also be things like
dysgraphia
um
I think representative ball may be able
to elaborate more on some of the other
disorders because
I don't know that I know all of them
offhand she probably knows the entire
list off the top of her head I can only
think of dysgraphia as a second one all
right well thank you further questions
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
this bill
um
we had some constituent email I'm not
sure if the person who sent it might be
testifying but it was an inquiry about
adding hearing screening because of the
correlation between hearing deficit and
misdiagnosis of Dyslexia and I just
wondered if that had been entertained at
all or if you could speak to that or
someone else who's testifying
yeah thank you for the question so
hearing screening is provided currently
as a newborn and then it's also provided
at the 2 4
5 6 and 7 well visits I believe and so
these are they're being provided as part
of the the children's pediatric visits
and so implementing that in school may
be a little bit redundant and I'm also a
little bit hesitant that
if a child is at all anxious or they're
around other kids who are also talking
and it may not be perfectly quiet they
may be getting flagged on a screening
like that unnecessarily typically if
this is alerted as a special ed case
then they would
get the screening for that but just in
terms of the general population doing it
I think it would be a bit repetitive
plus costly I think the cost of the
machines is roughly
two to three thousand plus the training
of the nurses on how to use them
thank you
further questions
thank you very much
I'd like to invite uh Karen Abel
representative evil up
Welcome to our committee thank you
foreign
for the record my name is Karen Ebel I
represent Merrimack District 7 which is
New London and Newbury I'm I'm here
primarily to provide some historical
context for the dyslexia bill
um back in 2015 my district made
representative David Kidder introduced a
bill to create a legislative excuse me
study committee to look into dyslexia
education at the behest of our
constituent BB Casey who will testify
later I was very eager to co-sponsor it
this issue is personal to me my sister
is dyslexic and wasn't diagnosed until
she was a junior in high school her son
my nephew has dyslexia and received very
little support in school now his
daughter is facing the same issue having
dyslexia presents extreme problems for
those who don't have the proper support
there's no question that dyslexia can
present challenges for a child and their
family but these challenges shouldn't go
on for decades fortunately in 2016 the
legislature with the support of this
committee passed a law to improve
dyslexia education and support early
intervention for reading challenges
generally
the 2015 study committee of which
representative cordelli was a member
revealed how much lacking was lacking in
educational opportunities for students
with dyslexia
dysgraphia and dyscalculia which I
learned how to say during the process
and how much they suffered personally
and professionally because their
condition was missed
we learned that with early intervention
based initially on simple free screening
tools children with potential problems
could be helped and their chances at
success grew exponentially
with early intervention and
evidence-based prac best practices many
children could even avoid IEPs
school districts should be able to save
precious dollars in the long run with
proper early intervention and
Educational Tools and children will
thrive
we were surprised to learn that indicia
of Dyslexia were not taught in teaching
colleges so our T many teachers at that
time were not trained to recognize them
we decided schools would benefit greatly
from the Department of Education reading
special specialist as a source of
information for dyslexia information
intervention and support
reading as you all well know is the
Cornerstone of all learning
and is critical for career Readiness of
any type and for college being able to
read is the key to the kingdom as your
committee knows well dyslexia is the
most common type of learning disability
I haven't looked at recent statistics
but at the time of our study 10 to 15
percent of our population had some form
of Dyslexia including at that time it
was twelve thousand students I believe
representative kutab just said ten
thousand perhaps some of you your family
and friends and that is a really huge
number of people
it was a happy day in 2016 when the
resulting legislation to support our
children and our schools past putting
into place the statute that we're
recommending be amended today the
program has been successful but like
anything some deficiencies have been
identified I'm regret I'm grateful to
representative kutab for bringing HB 377
which seeks to improve New Hampshire's
dyslexia education program focusing
primarily on increased screening and
prompt appropriate follow-up these
simple tools applied early and
frequently can help our children to
thrive
I am truly humbled to be before this
committee today knowing how much you
have to do and how much important work
you have done in the past and I really
don't have the expertise that you have
in the field of education and would ask
that any specific questions be addressed
to The Experts here today much of the
work you do is profoundly challenging
and I do thank you for what you do this
is an improvement to a very good law and
I hope it presents a simple decision for
you more screening is good our children
our school districts our communities and
our state will all benefit by helping
these children to thrive this is a goal
we all share and I urge you to recommend
passage of HB 377 and thank you for your
previous support of children with
dyslexia and their family thank you very
much representable I can remember when
Jack Falcon was sitting right beside me
here as Vice chair of this committee
when we did this yeah initially it's
very exciting are there any questions
or are you off the hook I am and I
apologize I have to go to another thank
you thank you very much
next uh individual is representative
Laurie ball
welcome hi good afternoon thank you for
allowing me to testify I appreciate the
time
laughs
I do have written testimony that I will
pass out
there's no doubt that early intervention
is crucial to a child's educational
development that's why we have child
find at age two and a half research
research shows that many Educators and
medical professionals can spot learning
disabilities far earlier than previously
thought as a reading and writing
specialist with an emphasis in dyslexia
I am well versed at spotting students
who are not processing information
correctly during covet
while doing remote learning with a child
who was in kindergarten it only took me
10 minutes to say that he was not
processing information correctly in
reading and math yet it took a year for
the school to identify that child for
reading intervention and two years to
refer that child to special education
my experience as an educational advocate
in New Hampshire has shown me that this
time frame is Not Unusual
I do not find fault with the general
education teachers who have not been
trained to recognize the signs of
dyslexia and I understand why some
teachers even when they know that there
is possibly a problem may be reluctant
to to refer that child for intervention
that's because I know that there are
some things that are beyond the general
education teachers control
in New Hampshire many school districts
follow an Unwritten rule of thumb
students must be one year behind grade
level to be referred for special for
intervention and two years behind grade
level to be referred to special
education
although that may sound shocking this
happens because the New Hampshire rules
of Education of the children with
disabilities provides that option
for the IEP team to deny evaluating
a student until they quote determine
whether the concerns raised by the
referral can be addressed utilizing
existing pupil service supports
available to all children in the school
this caveat is why it is imperative that
we move forward with the amendment to HB
to utilize evidence-based screening to
quickly identify students who need
intervention and or specialized
instruction
this house bill Amendment will assure
that students do not fall so far behind
that they will never catch up to their
same grade level peers
in addition it helps to assure that
students
will not be caught in a situation where
they are still trying to learn to read
While others are reading to learn
at this point you might be asking
yourself well this amendment really make
a difference well let me tell you about
children with dyslexia children with
dyslexia typically have average to above
average IQs as I would tell many of the
students I worked with Albert Einstein
was dyslexic
students with dyslexia quickly teach
themselves compensating strategies to
keep up with their classmates they
follow along listen and memorize words
as they see and hear them
students with dyslexia can fly under
their teacher's radar for years
this is an example of my personal
experiences
one student an 11th grade student who
started having difficulty keeping up was
found to have a grade 2 reading level
the psychologists who tested that
student commented that he was surprised
he did not become a discipline problem
or drop out of school
an eighth grade student I worked with
had an IQ of 115. she was referred
she started coming to school every day
late
she was referred to be identified as a
student with emotional disability
I don't know if I mentioned but in
addition to being a reading specialist
I'm also an emotional behavioral
specialist so I was at the IEP team at
the IEP meeting
in order to identify her except that I
quickly realized that she was
deliberately missing language arts and
social studies I suggested that we rule
out a reading disability everyone
thought I was crazy
but they let me do it
she could not read
she figured out how to read along by
memorizing your words and when she was
seeing them and hearing them just like I
mentioned it before
we've gotten all the way to letter J
when I said to her how do you know that
says Jay
and just to back up a little bit the
expectation is that a student should be
able to identify a letter or a word
within three seconds so as I'm sure all
of you sitting here can probably just do
it you just go you know
um but she was taking too long we got to
the letter J and I said how did you know
that that said you
and she said because I know that jump
starts with j and I backed out all the
other sounds and I figured it out that's
how much is going on in their heads
constantly to learn to read or just to
be able to look like they know how to
read
as it turns out
I am now hearing that the district is
now ruling out dyslexia
before identifying any students with an
emotional disability
my experience working with children with
emotional disabilities is that when I
started to peel the onion back I would
say eight out of the ten children that I
worked with I found the reading
disability
they were not mostly Disturbed
they were frustrated
the impact of failing to catch students
who are struggling to learn to read
early in their educational career
can mean years if not a lifetime
irreparable harm
academically socially emotionally and
economically
is that an overestimate no
our society continues to measure
intelligence by fluency
in schools that means how fast does a
child read how fast can they do math
problems as I pointed out last week the
academic evaluations used to identify
children for special education include
components that measure students fluency
in writing and math those same
evaluations measure reading fluency
students including young students know
when they are not measuring up to their
same grade peers those struggling
students
are those struggling with reading often
feel inferior to their peers which
causes their self-esteem to erode
this opens the door for a host of social
emotional factors as many of my students
have told me I would much rather be seen
as bad than stupid
the vet is far too many students never
get identified
as evident when you look at the
graph that I give you
okay until later on in their school
years often they're 10 11 12 years old
when they're being identified with a
specific learning disability
last year our education commissioner
Frank edelblue said that 42 000 New
Hampshire students were not reading a
proficient great at proficient levels
this is far more students than we have
identified for special education
so that means there's many out there
still languishing and not getting the
attention or interventions they need
as part of what I brought is the same
chart last year but they put out a new
one so this is updated to 2022 instead
of the 21. if you look at the
disbursement of the 10
000 77 students identified for special
for specific learning disabilities which
as we know is basic literacy skills you
can see that students are still being
identified sld in Upper Elementary and
Middle School ages that's because they
were able to fly under the radar until
they had multi-syllabic words and could
no longer memorize
their compensating strategies no longer
worked
knowing that quality intervention takes
typically two to two and a half years to
implement with Fidelity many of these
students would have already completed
the Intervention Program if they had
been identified earlier
clearly screening earlier and often in
grades kindergarten through grade two
will give teachers more opportunities to
identify struggling readers allow
districts to provide interventions
needed quickly and provide a means for
students to access the general education
curriculum without frustration
in closing I would offer this argument
if we know that a quality reading
Intervention Program for children
struggling to learn to read typically
takes two and a half years to implement
and if we understand that students who
are not reading a grade level by grade 3
may never read a grade level
and if we recognize that reading at
grade level not reading at grade level
has severe negative impact on the
student's ability to fully access the
general education curriculum
then we would take proactive steps to
assure all struggling students are
identified
as early as possible and provide
appropriate intervention
so that they can fully access access and
participate in the general education
curriculum alongside their same grade
peers
in addition to this testimony I have
another couple a piece of evidence I
would like to share with you and it is
an excerpt only because I made the
assertion
that my observation is the not getting
intervention for a year and not getting
uh referred to special ed for two years
I offer this
this is an excerpt from the United
States Department of Education it's
actually Dem dated January 21st 2011.
this problem's been going on for a long
time
and it describes how the schools are
offering tiered interventions one of
which is what we refer to as response to
intervention that's the general
education intervention that these
children would be referred to
but unfortunately
many school districts are using that
caveat to hold off on pushing them
forward to get evaluations for special
education they want to make sure that
all everything else is exhausted
even though our United States Department
of Education said it would be
inconsistent with the evaluation
provisions
to reject a referral or delay Provisions
for an initial evaluation on the basis
that that child has not participated in
an RTI framework
so we should not be using intervention
as a reason to delay or deny special
educational evaluations
in addition I had correspondence with
our own state
Department of Education to ask them
about why this happens if it really
happens with this two-year and it was
confirmed that because districts are
left with the ability to set guidelines
um
like this regarding evaluations they
vary from District to District
we need to tighten this up we need to
shorten the timelines and we need to get
interventions to struggling readers as
soon as possible thank you thank you
very much are there questions for
representative
yes represent dry thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking this up
it says on the the fiscal note in the
end or the chart there that it says an
indeterminable increase
um this is a lot of tests that are going
on is there a cost to this
which one are you referring to this um
no I'm referring to the yeah oh I'm
sorry
um that I would not be able to answer
I'm sorry but I would be able to say
that in the upper grades
um
you could just give a spelling test and
you can figure out the kids that are not
they don't know their phonics if they
can't spell they're not able to read
either they don't know the rules
um the test that I give it's a um in the
upper grades it's also for the lower
grades
I give it individually I think the test
itself costs about 150 dollars but I
Implement that to all the students that
I um then assess it's called the um
oh the West
the word in identification and spelling
test
you may follow up yes I think I'm
referring to the one that was
specifically talked about in the bill
um
online
five yep yep oh the Dibbles
um I I will be honest I have never
um implemented the Devils because I was
in the middle school but I do understand
that that one is also looking at fluency
and we do have what used to be known as
the gold standard for dyslexia was
called a Ras Rand it's a rapid automatic
naming automaticity naming that's a very
quick test to give
I am not a fan of putting
expecting children to words to read
specific numbers of words that has kind
of Fallen by the wayside we now say that
fluency is having the children read at a
speed in which they can comprehend
and so we should not be really measuring
that anymore
thank you
further questions
yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair my question relates
to
um the the frequency and amount of
testing done now I'm sure we all know
that no test is absolutely 100 perfect
um there there must be some rate of
false positives that come along with
this and do we have any idea what that
is and how that might impact
like how many students could possibly be
impacted being put on this path that are
not necessarily needing it
it's not really a path because it would
be an approach to how we're teaching
with regard to how far along I will tell
you that I thought it should go through
Middle School at least once a year
screening
these children are very difficult to
even
recognize them because they
they are really proficient at hiding
their disability
personally I even would say I hate
referring it to it as a disability I
think it's only a disability because our
education system is geared for
left-brained Learners and dyslexics
tends to be a right brain learner so if
we would match up how our children learn
to how we teach
that would solve the problem right there
and I think that that's what this
screening does it really is going to
look at whether or not they have those
skills needed for what we would normally
think of as more like in phonics being
able to recognize letter sounds word
sounds put them together pull them apart
and manipulate them and children
um
some children actually need to learn
that I would say that there's also with
children with dyslexia
it's in sometimes it's an auditory
disability if a child had a lot of ear
infections
um
they were never they never heard the
sounds they never learned that
articulation and so they must be taught
it I know that my own son he had what
was called
immature speech growing up due to
um
your infections I was told oh don't
worry that will work itself out when
they start teaching phonics but we don't
teach phonics anymore so it never worked
itself out and he had to be explicitly
taught
are the further questions represents
I'm wondering
um how this is going to deal with the
issue that schools were
putting off
dealing with the issues or even testing
until they had somebody who could take
care of it and here we're going to be
finding these students the question is
what are we going to be doing is there
is there known standard ways of dealing
with this that a school would then do or
do they actually have to wait for that
speech reading Specialist or whatever
um
Etc
absolutely and thank you so much for
that question if the schools
would go back to teaching phonics or
even include phonics within their
reading lessons and if they would
explicitly
and systematically teach the rules of
reading and phonics this could all be
addressed in the general education
classroom and all students could benefit
from that Intervention which at that
point would just be part of the
curriculum
thank you thank you I have a question
for you yes sir um I was in education
many many years as well Elementary
education
and I've heard it stated several times
now that if we teach phonics is there
any data that you have stating that
schools are not teaching phonics now or
that we're doing what I heard you
earlier say that some types of programs
are needed by some children in other
words that it's learning style teaching
style line those two together and I
think you got it however
um
in my first days as an elementary school
principal and teacher there are a number
of different methods used to help kids
learn how to read some more event
phonics some were other methods which we
have
so summing up my question again I've
heard that it's stated now several times
not just by you that phonics isn't
taught anymore
do we want to really do we have data
that
you know support that
yes
thank you for that question there is
definitely data or data to to support
that in New Hampshire we have moved to a
balanced literacy program and in those
programs they teach word memorization
there is very little phonics they are
starting to integrate it now because in
the two main programs fontus and panel
and Lucy Calkins were debunked by
cognitive scientists who said that that
is not how teacher that children read
that using those programs we're teaching
children to read like disabled or
struggling readers we're teaching them
to memorize words to use strategies like
look at the picture in the book and then
you can figure out the word and yes
those are some strategies that we teach
children as we go along when we're
teaching them comprehension and we say
well look at the rest of the sentence or
look at the pictures but let me give you
an example
I was working with a child and we were
in for beginning of first grade
and we were sounding Out the word Pig
did it several several times and I asked
her let's pull it together what do we
have and I was so excited because I
thought she had it
and she looked up
and she looked all around like she was
trying to find some clue
and then she said rat
that's what's happening with the balance
balance literacy the children are
learning to rely on these strategies
instead of learning the letter sounds
and putting them together to make words
it has been extremely detrimental and we
have known this for years as I said I
could provide you with the research or
the articles that I'm stating that were
written in 2018 that say that's the
balance literacy is not how to teach
children how to read
thank you thank representative Cass
Academy
thank you Mr chair I'm going to rely on
your professionalism thank you for all
your information I appreciate it I too
was an educator many years not as far
back those representative Ladd
um oh
I'm sorry I owe
um
the question that I have thinking about
this big picture and if you're you know
there's data out there supporting that
these assessments are not done in a
timely manner to be able to catch the
disability
do you foresee I mean I know that there
are schools that do not have reading
Specialists because it adds a cost to
their budget right personnel
but if this were implemented do you
foresee that teachers could implement
this
with intervention or would they require
reading Specialists on staff because I
know how valuable a reading specialist
is
in support of you know the the reading
instruction
I do not just hear that
I do not believe that doing these types
of screenings would require a reading
specialist to do that I think that the
general education teacher can do the
screenings
and it's it's the identifying them and
then addressing it immediately that's
where there seems to be the Gap is
getting that intervention to them as
fast as possible
I will say that those two reading
programs that I mentioned fontus and
Pinnell and the Lucy Hawkins are and
actually Lucy Hawkins there is an actual
article where she admits that her
program does not work and that she did
not understand the science of reading
when she put that program together
but those two programs now are
scrambling to integrate the phonics into
their programs
um I don't know how that's going to work
because
um
when I look at the little books that
they're giving them to read if we look
at fontus and panel they have a a way of
reading a letter A B C what what letter
are you on and I look at the ones that
are early readers and I'm just like oh
you got to be kidding me
I mean I know what the scope and
sequence is to teaching reading and I'm
looking at these little books and I'm
like well there's a closed syllable
there's a magic e there's a r control
word there's a you know and
a whole nother syllable type
these children haven't been taught so
it's obvious the only way they can read
these little beginner readers is that
they're memorizing them
and that's where we're having the
problems we really need to match
um how we teach to how our children
learn
Jefferson Woodcock thank you chairman
good afternoon thank you everybody's
information about
um I agree with a lot particularly the
emotionally intervention and the
frustration and then suspending instead
of maybe look foolish much easier and as
they mature and get the higher grade
levels they prefer to be seeing the sent
down the principal's office than being
in school and not be able to read and
just goes on and on but my question is
is a request you indicated to
representative Vlad that you had
information based on the New Hampshire
basically and how ineffective it was
right he said I missed what you had you
had uh an article for information
Mark that you answered representative
Ladd my request is that you email that
data to the full leg committee
absolutely thank you absolutely thank
you thank you for the questions
representative Tana
thank you thank you for taking my
question and thanks for bringing your
expertise to this
um very important issue how do we reach
those students that are going to Charter
Schools or uh maybe are homeschooled is
it is this any of this testing to child
find or
um can be done any anywhere in the
community that would catch these
children I would think it would be able
to I would think that the uh teachers in
the charter school can also Implement
these screenings I'd have to look at and
know what which uh reading program the
charter schools are using I will say
that I know that the Parochial School in
my town teaches phonics and they always
have they've never went to balanced
literacy
so
representative Belgium
thank you Mr chair
um you indicated that if uh if New
Hampshire were to return to a
phonics-based learning model it would it
would really solve the underlying
problem here and probably eliminate the
need for a lot of this so is there any
is there going to be a bill forthcoming
perhaps to that would that would do that
I believe there is a bill that will be
coming that's going to bring phonics and
try and get phonics back in keep in mind
that phonics is not a whole reading
program it's only a piece of it we still
have to address the vocabulary we still
have to address the
um
comprehension and all the other five
components of reading
um but yes I do
know that there is a bill coming forth
you'll see me again
thank you very much I'm very pleased to
hear you say it's not the only component
because I was thinking vocabulary
comprehension we used to have the gay
community test and but I can remember a
lot of old SRA science research
Associates one of the titles of the book
is I recall a pig can jig now there you
go uh and well that was the topic of one
of the books and I think that was that
first or beginning that would be a
closed syllable first thing that they're
going to learn got the Blends the
digraphs and everything done
uh further questions we do have some
other people here to testify today
thank you very much thank you so much
Phoebe
is it Casey welcome
thank you okay
good afternoon
uh my name is Bibi Casey uh I'm from New
London I am a co-founding member of the
New Hampshire chapter of decoding
dyslexia which there's somebody behind
me is hoping to testify who's a current
uh president of the decoding dyslexia in
New Hampshire I've also been a board
member of New Hampshire International
dyslexia Association I'm a school board
member in the Kearsarge Regional School
District and I'm a parent of a dyslexic
child I testified in front of this
Committee in 2015 as representative evil
mentioned in support of at the time it
was HB 1644 and that eventually became
what we call the dyslexia law my son
testified as well
at the time he was finishing his first
semester at Plymouth State and he
testified to you that he never imagined
ever going to college when he was in
Middle School today he's working as an
architect design intern in Gloucester
Massachusetts he has one more semester
to finish a master's in architecture and
will be licensed at the end of the year
his school did not have a screening
process in K-2 he struggled through
Elementary School the teachers did not
have the knowledge or experience to
identify with why he was struggling and
it wasn't until I requested an
evaluation in sixth grade when he was
finally identified
our family sacrifice we sent him to a
private high school that specialized in
teaching students with language-based
learning disabilities to get him the
help he needed to succeed he was lucky
because our family had the resources but
most students aren't that lucky
I don't blame those teachers who didn't
understand his disability they were
trying so hard to help him they just
didn't know what they didn't know
HB 377 is in support of Educators and
getting them the help they need to
support their students
I'm here today to ask you to support HB
377 the bill is basically a
clarification of the current dyslexia
law I was a member of the study
committee who worked on the original
draft and since the law was passed we
have heard from any school personnel
with questions on best practices on
screening both timing and frequency and
I know the doe also has heard a lot of
these questions and the doe published a
very good resource guide that is
available on their website plus they did
a lot of professional development
sessions around the state and there are
schools that are doing this the right
way I had a long conversation with our
curriculum directors in Kearsarge
yesterday afternoon they are in full
support of this bill they were have been
working very hard over the last few
years and putting in a process in place
a protocol in place that follows what
this bill is describing here
representative ball talked about
Fountains of Pennell and Lucy Calkins
the secure search District was using
reading recovery which is the Lucy
culligans program they've thrown it out
and they have been working very hard on
redoing their curriculum when it comes
to this stuff
um
and I I especially am uh happy to see
that the screening requirement is now
going kindergarten through second grade
you've already heard from people that
have testified already how important it
is to catch it as early as possible I
don't need to repeat that all for you
all over again but uh we've had
questions in the past too of oh well
I've I've screened in kindergarten now I
don't have to screen again because
that's what the law says because people
didn't weren't reading it correctly so
I'm confident that this amendment kind
of tightens up that language to make it
more clear that the screening really is
necessary all the way through K through
two in case it's missed it can be done
and oh and and cancer District they're
actually doing it more than twice a year
and it depends on the tool the tool will
specify how much time in between the
screening should be done and how often
it can be done to be done you know
uh the correct way uh
I don't I've submitted this testimony
online I have copies if anybody wants it
I just want to finish up because your
time is very valuable with saying I am
so grateful uh I was so grateful at the
time when the original bill was support
was filed with bipartisan support I am
grateful today to representative kutab
for introducing this bill and continuing
with the bipartisan support progress has
been made in many school districts
throughout the state since the original
law was passed the pandemic threw a
monkey wrench into many things but I'm
confident that this will help continue
that progress and in the long run help
so many students in the state become
successful members of our communities
happy to take any questions thank you
very much are there any questions
from the committee thank you thank you
uh next card I have here is Jen black
moth
that production name correctly yeah
hi I'm Jennifer blagriff I'm from
Hopkinton New Hampshire and I'm one of
the current decoding dyslexia State
leaders so I'm grateful for that this
bill was brought forward
um myself and Allison Everhart are there
two current decoding dyslexia leaders
um I have four children my oldest is 13
and he has dyslexia my second oldest is
10 and she also has dyslexia
um My Little second grader she's doing
all right I've definitely seen the
improvements in the school districts the
school district that my kids are in they
have really been embracing the science
of reading and improving their teaching
methods which has been absolutely
wonderful
um and then my little one is he's four
so I don't know he has some potential
red flags we'll see what happens
um so
um I submitted this testimony and I have
some copies here
um so I'll just read a little bit from
the letter
um so well Allison and I are very much
in support of the improvements offered
by HB 377 FN we strongly recommend
further changes to this bill at this
time including the following that the
screening tool include a test of Rapid
automized naming or ran the screening be
implemented through the third grade year
and that parents and Guardians receive
screening results
so it's critical that this will be
expanded to specifically state that the
screener include ran ran is a strong
predictor of future reading difficulty
across different ages ability levels and
languages and we have a reference on
here for you guys and so it is a key
component a component of any early
literacy screening and I believe the
dipples 8 does have ran as a component
um second secondly this bill must
address the third grade year we feel
very strongly about about this as
parents and from things we've heard from
other parents that third grade year we
still need to be doing screening at this
point in time
so while many school districts in New
Hampshire are improving the weights of
fail model is still present it is often
not until the third grade year after
that children are identified as having
significant enough difficulties to
Warrant concern often requiring
intervention that is more intensive and
thus more costly well while we
understand this bill is designed to help
address this issue the bill must include
the third grade year given the critical
needs of identifying reading challenges
by third grade so we have great concerns
that there will still unfortunately be
kids missed in that kindergarten first
and second grade year as systematic
change takes time to happen
and even though this bill could greatly
improve things through second grade I
there's that third grade year is
critical at this point
lastly this bill needs to explicitly
state that all parents and Guardians
receive the results of screening so that
needs to be spelled out very clearly
that it is all parents
um and that it should also be spelled
out that it should be sent home with the
next report card with an explanation of
the screening tool or tools used it is
critical that parents have an
understanding of the screenings being
conducted as well as how their children
are performing on these screenings in
order to be able to support their
children as readers lots of parents do
not realize until it's in a sense too
late that their kids were struggling
earlier on so it's the parents are you
know the key person to really understand
how these kiddos are doing and they
really should know what those screening
results are from the beginning to the
end
um
so we feel these suggested changes will
have significant impacts and will
require a little additional cost if any
long-term savings will occur over time
as students are identified an
intervention is implemented early
avoiding the way to fail model will
result in decreased costs and fewer
students referred for special education
which as you likely all know special ed
involves a lot of um you know man
Manpower time and money
um
and then New Hampshire is definitely in
an exciting period of transition where
many teachers are fully embracing the
science of reading to teach all children
to read
and critical to that is the
implementation of Dyslexia screening
tools that follow reading science best
practices we're grateful for your work
to improve our state dyslexia
legislation and ask that you add the
requested changes to further align with
the reading science evidence to better
support New Hampshire student learning
and build their Pathways to success and
then at the bottom we just have
highlighted our suggestions of how this
bill could be further improved thank you
very much are there any questions from
the committee
MPS rips in Woodcock thank you chairman
good afternoon thank you for coming in
thanks and providing your information uh
what grade does the Rand become a useful
test I actually do not know the answer
to that as a parent there might be
someone that could I believe it's I mean
my guess is it's through the grades I
think it's a normal thing that my kids
have had even when they've been tested
older as a part of special ed testing
but that's just a guess thank you thank
you thank you for the questions
thank you very much and the reference on
there may explain that
reps and Lauren set selling
thank you and hello to the education
committee I am representative Lauren
selig from Durham New Hampshire
um and you were one of the Committees I
did not get appointed to but was hoping
for so um I thank you for having the
opportunity to speak before you
um I am a former teacher I started my
career teaching kindergarten in a
setting where we
um the first school where I taught was
uh pseudo Montessori
um and then I moved to a school where we
team taught and I was the person in
charge of teaching reading to our
kindergartners
um my co-teacher taught all the math not
surprisingly we discovered that by doing
one-on-one reading instruction every
child was able to learn to read it his
or her best rate because he or she got
it at the style and method which worked
best for them
um additionally I then went to Johns
Hopkins University in Baltimore to get a
master's degree in education
um while I was there the city of
Baltimore expended five million dollars
to conduct a study on reading and
literacy and discovered that children
who are taught one-on-one or in small
groups learn to read faster than
students who don't really really
surprising
but I also am the parent of two
dramatically different children one of
my daughters began reading when she was
three and a half
um we were out and about and she's like
look Mommy there is Matt I was like what
and she pointed and the word Matt was on
you know some sign
um and so it was a race to keep up with
her and her reading ability
um my other daughter however at age
three still couldn't identify the M on
the big yellow signs that we all see as
we drive down the highway and didn't
recognize that letter she also couldn't
recognize the first letter of her first
name which I didn't expect her to know
the alphabet at three but I did think
she would recognize the first letter of
her first name
um because I'm a former teacher because
I had worked teaching children to read
it was clear to me that we had a
challenge with her learning and we also
live in a district that Prides itself on
the special education services as it
gives to others
despite all that I had to fight and
fight and fight our school district to
have her evaluated for any kind of
learning disability at all
and ultimately I was successful but only
with the support of teachers who are
willing to go to bat and fight with me
um and she has incredibly amazingly
smart and funny and Savvy young person
but she also lost from kindergarten
until halfway through third grade
without being able to read effectively
because it wasn't until she was halfway
through second grade that we discovered
her eyes did not track properly
and my mortification the day that she
said to me mommy did you know that trees
have individual leaves
was awful as a parent to have my child
be almost eight years old and not have
realized that that green blob was
individual separated leaves and it
wasn't for my lack of trying to have her
evaluated but part of that was
age-appropriate mess so I've heard a
number of people talk about the
importance of extending this bill
through Kinder through third grade
I think really we need to continue to
offer some form of testing whether it's
opt-in all the way through the
elementary years and probably into the
middle school years so that we are
catching a lot of these visual
disruptions I don't agree that phonics
is the only way to teach children to
read There are some children for whom
that is incredibly successful there are
some children who don't process
auditorily and that's never going to be
a successful method for them we need to
be able to offer varieties but I think
it's important to use this to use tools
like this bill to expand it Beyond
second grade and to look for ways that
we can really be evaluating all of our
children to see how they learn and to
support their learning best
thank you very much are there questions
not seeing me thank you thank you very
much thank you you're welcome and the
last pink parrot I have is Kathleen
McCaffrey
okay that's
so I'm Kathleen McCaffrey I'm here to
answer any questions from the Department
of Education I've worked 12 years in an
elementary school setting seven years in
a clinical setting with neurodiversity
students testing and additionally I'm
getting a PhD in orthographic mapping
from Northeastern University
so any questions you have regarding the
bill I can maybe answer
other questions
well there are a few hands over here
representative Drive okay thank you for
uh Mr chairman and thank you for taking
this um I'm going to ask the question I
did before which is if we use the um the
tool recommended in the bill to test and
and ramp up our number of tests um is
there a cost to that
so that's an interesting question I
reached out to Matt Burns who works at
the University of Missouri education and
he's done longitudinal studies on
screeners and there's a variety of
screeners that are zero cost that he
does recommend including the Dibbles
versus there's two different forms of
Dibbles which you asked so it depends on
the type of screener I guess that the
school district would choose and that's
why it's indeterminable because it
depends again we're local control and
the districts can choose what they would
like to use
yes the statue really conflicts this
whole thing when districts have total
authority over instruction and
curriculum what they use it's not a
mandate down from us uh for
representative Belcher do you also have
your hand up
thank you Mr chair just to seek further
clarification I'll I'll ask you the same
question I asked earlier which is
um of course all tests being imperfect
do we have any information regarding
rates of possible false positives for
many of these tests all tests have false
positives in fact I was looking at Matt
Burns study when you asked that question
and he does say that and he recommends
using a variety of different tests in
order to get rid of false positives some
tests again are free but he does say
that there is always going to be false
positives on tests and he has done again
five years longitudinal data I'm happy
to give you this articles afterwards
where you can really dive into the data
does the department take a position on
this bill
I am not sure
are there further questions
thank you very much thank you
so this closes this hearing and we will
get ready here to open up the next
hearing which we have today is
um 429 requiring the offering of
breakfast and lunch in all public and
Charter Public Schools
take a little bit of a stretch here
folks and we'll start this up in about a
minute so
thank you
yes
Sue how are you doing
foreign
of course I do not have art Allison have
you down there by Bill
y
chips so there's two hours behind so I
will step out when they text me but okay
sorry yeah that's okay
this looks like 29 on radio right
yeah he had two of them now okay
we're going to go ahead now and start
with HP 429 429 is a bill requiring
offering of breakfast and lunch in all
public and Charter Public Schools
Welcome to our committee representative
Allison
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of this esteemed committee uh
I will be introducing House Bill 429 FM
local uh the intent of the bill is to
decrease the number of students in New
Hampshire Public Schools who come to
school hungry and to provide a level of
nutrition to those students that will
allow them to be successful in their
classrooms a change from what uh you
will have well I mentioned it in my
testimony but there will be Amendment
forthcoming which will pull charter
schools out out of this bill
and we will address that in in future
legislation so the bill as amended will
require every public school in the state
to participate in the federal breakfast
lunch program under RSA 189 2A this bill
is a result of over two years of work by
members of this committee uh former
members of this committee uh who spent
lots of time with research a study
committee uh gen 404 from our committee
provided us with lots and lots of
information
uh that committee was ably led by
representative Sue Mullen who has that
knows probably more about this topic
than almost anyone else and she'll be
testifying today
this is the first in a number of bills
that will come here into other health
committees related to reducing hunger in
our for our children
our research in this area is
overwhelmingly supportive of the link
between student learning gains and
healthy meals
there's a growing support for vastly
increasing the number of students
receiving healthy meals through their
schools in December 2021 as reported in
Irwin institute's well-being and basic
National needs survey almost 70 percent
of the respondents supported permanent
free School meals for all students in
addition we have multiple reports that
provided to us from Jen which relate to
significant progress that's being made
in this area in the surrounding states
of Massachusetts Maine and Vermont
here in New Hampshire we often are not
swayed by national surveys or what other
states might be doing on a particular
topic we try to stay focused on the best
interests of our children
child hunger is not a republican nor a
democratic issue it is certainly within
the responsibility of this committee
when hungry children cannot learn to
take even more even small measured steps
toward improving their educational lives
but it is it is even more important
particularly for children to meet their
most basic human need no more hunger
I hope the committee will ultimately
debate and vote to move this floor bill
as amended to the house floor without to
pass recommendation I I would add you
have a you have information relating
from the Department of Education
relating to the number of of schools
that this might affect we receive very
recent information in the last 45
minutes to clarify this uh there are six
schools six public schools in the state
of New Hampshire that currently do not
provide breakfast and lunch through the
federal program
and there are 27
I think I've got this right 27 uh
Charters uh
schools who operate these are public
schools who provide dinner but not
breakfast so we're talking about this
bill at this point as amended affecting
the 27 schools that you'll provide
breakfast in the six schools that
provide neither dinner nor or lunch or
breakfast just as a trying to put this
in this context I'd be happy to try to
answer any questions there are other
people that will follow me up here we'll
probably have more answers than I will
have but I will do my best thank you
very much representative Allison do you
have a pink card for us no I did not oh
you're gonna have to do that all over
again no I will be sure that it gets
there thank you very much are the
questions for representative Allison yes
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question I just want
to make sure I have the numbers right
you said six Public Schools no breakfast
or lunch and that's not Charters that's
right 27 public not Charters no
breakfast that's correct okay thank you
further questions
thank you very much
I'd like to welcome back honorable Sue
Mullen
we've saved all that ammunition for you
thank you very much chairman Ladd I
noticed that uh representative Ellison
received one question on introducing the
bill so uh
and I immediately uh turned around and
said who it who defers to Kelly Rambo
from the Department of Education on
every fact and figure thank you uh
chairman Ladd and members of the
committee for hearing me today
uh during the last session this
committee heard a number of bills
regarding student hunger
the acknowledgment of the problem and
interest in seeking Solutions led to the
establishment of the study committee on
house bill 1229 which uh representative
and chair Ladd appointed me chair of
Representatives Allison Hall Woodcock
lekinson Ford all served on that study
committee which met consistently last
summer and fall
Jennifer four as mentioned your talented
research assistant was able to pull
together information from five states
with similar demographics to see what
initiatives they had in place to address
the needs of their hungry kids
those states are Delaware Maine New
Mexico Vermont and West Virginia
I believe that most committee members
would tell you that they learned quite a
lot by going through the process of
studying that bill
Maine requires all schools to
participate in the national school lunch
program Vermont requires participation
in both breakfast and lunch West
Virginia requires all schools to operate
a school nutrition program that provides
both breakfast and lunch though the
national school lunch program is not
specified
information provided by our own New
Hampshire hunger Solutions ranks New
Hampshire as 47th out of 50 states in
school breakfast participation even
though we know that students who are fed
demonstrate improved academic
performance
reduce behavioral problems improved
attendance higher graduation rates and
fewer trips to the nurse
in 2021 nearly half of the students who
qualified for free or reduced meals went
without even an opportunity for
breakfast in New Hampshire
and the state missed an opportunity to
feed 7 800 additional students by
leaving 1.5 million federal dollars on
the table
New Hampshire hunger Solutions has a
wealth of information and ideas about
how to address food insecurity and I
strongly encourage this committee to
reach out to them for help in any
measures that you craft from this point
forward I know that they're with us
today and will be following me I'm sure
at this microphone
student hunger is real
I know many of you will voice a concern
about the cost of requiring
participation in a meals program and I
share those concerns
but the reality is the communities are
going to pay for Hungry kids one way or
another be it increased special ed
services behavior management or future
unemployment
I have heard New Hampshire described as
the best place to live but I would
challenge that that is not the
perception for families who struggle to
put food on the table and a roof over
their heads
communities require a partnership with
the state to address the needs of their
most vulnerable populations yet past
efforts to expand the state's role have
been met with resistance or inaction at
best
there may be cries about whether or not
this represents an unfunded mandate
but those questions can be addressed
quite simply it's not an unfunded
mandate if we fund it
recently the front page of the union
leader heralded New Hampshire's 300
million dollar Surplus which today I
learned is actually 283 million uh so I
don't want to exaggerate the amount they
indicated in the in the newspaper that
there would be much discussion in
Concord about how to utilize the excess
Revenue
that in my opinion is an exercise in
setting priorities and what should be a
greater priority than caring for New
Hampshire's children
rather than filling our discussions
about why we can't expand the
opportunity for our hungry kids to eat I
would suggest that it's time to start a
serious conversation about what we can
do to assure that no economically
challenged child is distracted by an
empty stomach
we need to require school districts to
feed those who can't feed themselves and
offer those communities the help that it
requires to make it happen
I ask you to please support House Bill
429 I thank you for your time today and
it feels good to be home
thank you thank you very much now we can
ask those non-softball questions go for
it
what can I do for you chairman Ladd a
representative
you knew you were going to give me I I
would have I would have bet money on
that
so I'm wondering down where it says um
each School District shall participate
instead of which participates in the
National School breakfast program and
I'm wondering about schools like
Londonderry which have totally opted out
of any of the federal programs having to
do with meals and have decided to deal
with it entirely within their school
district do they need to take part in
this National School thing if they are
had figured out how to deal with it on a
district level right as you all know
representative fleckis because we talked
about this uh at Great length for months
uh I I don't really have an answer for
that there are in fact uh opportunities
for discussion and examination about
what would be gained or lost by a school
that privately provides the meals uh my
greater greater concern is for schools
that are not providing anything you know
that they're not involved in the
National program and they're not doing
anything on their own but school
districts like Londonderry and Hanover
you're going to have to have that
conversation because uh they uh they do
in fact provide meals but they are not
part of that National program
thank you
representative dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you uh for
taking this um can I look on the front
page of your testimony at the very third
line from the bottom and could you
explain to me how New Hampshire missed
the opportunity to feed 7 800 additional
students by leaving 1.5 million federal
dollars on the table oh generally it has
to do with the direct Medicaid
certification process we have the
opportunity to apply to be a state that
automatically certifies uh families
whose children are eligible for Medicaid
in the school lunch program and reduced
and free lunches uh it was a request it
was the requirement was that we fill in
an application and be accepted by it we
had a deadline and that application did
not go in by the deadline so therefore
we
we're not eligible to receive any of the
funds that went along with it okay okay
can I follow up yes uh so who's the we
the state of New Hampshire it's like the
Department of Education whose
responsibility is it it was the
department of education's uh purview to
submit the application okay thank you
you're welcome
uh honorable Mullen um I was going to
ask you the question about Hanover
um
see them up from that neck of the woods
is would you be opposed to some kind of
amending language to allow a a town like
Hanover which is feeding their
youngsters
and has the money to continue doing that
um so that we allow that ability for the
local to make the decision
form answer to the question but I will
tell you what my thoughts are about it I
would direct you to representative
Ellison who's the Prime sponsor about
whether or not he's comfortable with
with that Amendment uh but what the
questions that I would be asking in
Hanover in Londonderry would have to do
with how they accommodate kids who can't
afford to pay for lunch I mean we know
what the federal program does you have
to fill an application and be found
eligible and we know what the rates are
in a privately operated feeding system
what we would want to see obviously is
that in those situations if there were
families that couldn't afford the price
of the meal that the kids were fed
anyhow
yeah we know that Hanover the
afraid of trying to if Hanover being a
community where the free and reduced
population is less
than most districts in this state so if
they are able to assure that those
youngsters are going to be fed
would you have a problem with that
personally no okay
no I mean representative Noble is in a
similar situation bedford's free and
reduced lunch uh population is hovers
usually around five percent so you know
I don't think it would represent a heart
Londonderry might be a little different
because I my guess is that their freedom
reduced population is larger than that
but I don't know that it would represent
a hardship to those districts to even
have to provide free lunches for
eligible kids I think Londonderry would
have a problem with seeing that having a
problem with special education costs
yeah
all righty uh yes represent Balboni
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative Ramon
uh my question is uh do we know why uh
the the schools aren't participating the
six that don't have either or uh the 27
that don't provide the purpose I do not
have the answer to that but uh your
devoted and dedicated doe staff member
Kelly Rambo is behind me as I mentioned
she may have uh an impression on why
those six schools are not involved
we had an opportunity yesterday I asked
Kelly that she's here again today I see
you're here today
okay further questions
thank you very much for coming quite
welcome thanks for having me have a good
drive back to Bedford
okay reps in a woodcock
thank you chairman LED for the record my
name is Steve Woodcock and I work I
represent Conway South Conway North
Conway East Conway all the conways so
it's a pleasure to be here uh on this
slide at least temporarily uh we'll know
later if I like you know here uh before
we start I I do want to thank Kelly
Rambo and Jen as Arthur did uh and Sue
they've been uh insurmountable helping
us with assistance all year long and
Kelly even is as quickly as uh
representative Olson asked for some more
information yesterday afternoon and she
came through and she said she did and
always has so I'm gonna provide a very
uh simple approach uh to this bill
particularly after listening to
um representative Mullen and former
president Mullen I threw my other sheet
away because it's just me duplicate but
it's really a simple bill
um it has Suits that as a result of the
committee from the summer led by her
obviously and Alicia is in yours is
there
this like many of the bills are going to
follow over the next two years help
support both the structure for the
participation in public schools meals
program
the initial 429 Bill included Charter
Schools was mentioned but after much
discussion and phone calls written
testimony in addition to the information
that was presented just yesterday is
clear that only 15 percent of the
charter schools which equals only six by
the way at this point a currently
providing meals out of the 43 but it's
also clear that many other charter
schools are using vendor programs and
are servicing the youngsters so we're
taking that right out of the issue so we
get down to the the real task in hand
this bill this bill deals specifically
with the structure of providing two
meals a day for students in each of our
schools that's it it's not a heavy lift
those two schools already have the
facilities
I'm going to ask you I was going to have
an activity for you but I won't because
I I can see representative Cordell
you're getting over there bye I'm going
to ask you to just take a minute and
think about this little issue this this
I'm going to frame a different way
imagine if you will you are hosting
several people in your home this weekend
and they're arriving Friday night
and you're all hitting out early
Saturday morning for some fun time in
the beautiful White Mountains but you
have to provide a breakfast for this
group before I head out
and your task was going to be right down
but I won't I'm going to ask you to take
30 seconds and think about what you
might do Friday night before the
Saturday morning when this Live Crew in
your house goes down to breakfast just
think about what you might do in
preparation for that live group it'll
take a few seconds 10 seconds a few
quick people
okay now I want to ask anybody to speak
on that representative kennel uh but the
point of this activity which reminds you
there are many things that can be done
in advance of providing a nutritious
breakfast without a great amount of
extra work uh for example you may have
set the table you might have put out
paper phonics cups smoothies napkins
paper bowls five blocks of the cereal
where you get my point so Saturday
morning you just get up perk the coffee
set out the milk and Juice no heavy
lifting and you're on your way and
everybody has breakfast that is exactly
the point of this bill
this bill doesn't require bacon eggs
pancakes lots of cooking it doesn't
require multiple staff it's as simple as
setting up a quick grab and go
and I mentioned this because there were
only a small number of schools 27.
27 schools in our state that are not
doing this they're already providing
lunch folks they have the facilities
they have the kitchen they have the
staff we're not talking about much here
but the important part of this bill is
the option for students to begin their
day with nutritious flight meals please
understand these students have already
been identified as needing a breakfast
and a lunch they have been eligible for
are free or reduced breakfast and lunch
because they are in poverty aren't
getting the food they need this
assumption but we're not providing it we
all know it's better to feed the brain
so all I'm telling you in a very simple
way and not as eloquently as uh
honorable Mullins over there or Allison
just to get down their brass simple
facts this bill requires that all
schools that are receiving federal funds
to fulfill the obligation of providing
the two meals a day as they share to
those two youngsters that qualify it's
as simple as that
so that is that is what I have I'd be
more than happy to answer thank you are
there any questions representative
leckis
yeah you seem to be talking thank you
for taking my question
you you were seem to be talking about
providing these meals just for the free
and reduced lunch kids but the bill says
any well the uh every pupil under its
jurisdiction so are you then running a
not just grab and go but pay and all of
that for all students do all students
have to participate can any particip how
does it how does it the exactly thank
you for the question represent Lucas I'm
glad there's only one question alone
thank you
um it's actually just that simple that
it would be at breakfast it doesn't have
to be a big meal at a lunch meal but
everyone that walks through the door
wants to pay like they have their card
in the pr system they would do that but
the intent of the bill the reason for
the bill is to provide in those 27
schools where those youngsters did not
have a breakfast or reasonable nutrition
to come to school have the option to get
anyone we're assuming it's probably
incorrect that the other youngsters in
the school have already had breakfast
but that's probably not the case but
beyond that this they would allow me to
do this I guess my point at least they
don't have to create a whole lot of
stuff here it is take at least you have
something that gets just started and I
think we have that responsibility
because we've already identified them
saying you need that and we have the
opportunity to provide that but thank
you I didn't want to make it more
confusing than it was
thank you very much are there further
questions of Representative woodcock
I'd have no that's a pleasure thank you
I'd have snacks or Dunkin Donuts cards
at the house and hand them out
I'll be right there
I know you would be okay next one up to
on Deck here Tim uh representative Tim
Oregon
foreign
Stratford County District 10 which is
the town of Durham um and I won't even
be able to speak as eloquently as a
resident Woodcock she'll try to be quick
because it's kind of a it peaked it
peaked early he's going downhill from
here but I'm a co-sponsor to build and I
I want to make I think all all children
in all public schools should have a
access to breakfast a lot so no kid
should go hungry and no kid can learn if
they're if they're not hungry they're um
either the fiscal note I'm I'm kind of
baffled by that number 153 it seems like
uh they're not operating Public Schools
aren't doing School breakfast or lunch
I'm surprised it's so many I do know
um if we may need to tweet these
legislation to cover school districts
that aren't participating in the federal
program but our uh providing the
equivalent service of the kids that
would be appropriate
My Town also has a low percentage of
free and reduced uh students but it is a
significant percentage and we
participate in the federal program and
actually lived in Hanover for several
years I surprised to learn that it's
that it opted out but I'm um there may
actually have something to do the fact
that they're part of the interstate
School District too so like half of the
school district is in Vermont but um and
they have many many tuition students at
the high school but um
so that's uh so I'm certainly uh I'm
certainly amenable to doing any making
an amendments we have to do to get the
bill through the committee and through
all the other steps it has to be to
become law the main thing is to feed
more children um
I would have preferred leaving the
charter schools in because our public
schools that have all the same
responsibilities as conventional public
schools and uh
sometimes we let them off the hooks on
things and that artificially that
creates the impression that they're
doing it cheaper than they can in some
videos because we're just not asking to
do things that the regular schools have
to do and that may include lunch and I
think some of them
and some of them must be provided I
think as someone that I think are
providing uh school lunches and or
breakfasts already and they certainly
all should at some point whether we can
get there this year or not um apparently
parents get a chance we can't and so an
amendment to that amendment to make the
bill work
and get something passed this year would
be fine by me so um and I
yeah yeah sort of the chart just goes a
lot of them don't have you know the
cafeteria facilities in the building
like all regular schools would have so
that's um
so I'm basically and I underline
everything that uh the other
representative said so I uh you know you
have to work on the bill a little bit
but I urge you to pass it and also
there's a lot of concerns
about the uh about the cost
and some of you even try to claim it's
unconstitutional I think that's uh false
in any case
both in this committee and then I guess
it'll have to go to finance because it
says early Bill we're here
certainly
you know certainly if we pay for it then
there's no supposedly whatever article
12a issue there and um once you have the
school breakfast program it's all it's
largely it's mostly
self-subsidizing anyway because there's
a lot of federal money in there you also
have the families uh copay and then also
they sell meals to the adults who are
working in the school too at a at full
price so actually and it's not
particularly expensive to feed
defeat children anyway at least
certainly not expensive compared to the
value of the service so like it's uh
this is not really a big this is not
that big taking an item and uh you know
it pays you know pretty much uh paid
more than pays for itself so I would say
um
so I would say you know you make you
know it may need an amendment to tweak
some things I think the basic framework
of this bill is strong and I hope it uh
I hope you uh hope you send it on its
way to finance for the senate or well
with the other body we're not supposed
to mention or uh
and open to the governor's desk we can
sign it and get more kids fed so that's
what I have to say thank you very much
representative are there questions from
representative Horrigan yeah
thank you very much thank you
uh yes
a correction well why don't we wait and
let the other people are waiting first
okay and then we'll get your correction
yeah okay let's go on the next one
uh Lara Milliken
or Laura I know it was Lara Laura Laura
okay
this is Loris right there
go ahead thank you chairman Ladd and
members of the committee I provided you
with written testimony and sort of a
raft of uh the a summary of the research
that's available on the benefits of
School meals so I'll just keep my
comments brief
um School meals are essential to Student
Health learning and behavior
um
so I'm not sure if I said Laura Milliken
I'm the executive director of New
Hampshire hunger Solutions I'm sorry so
um uh School meals are essential to
Student Health learning and behavior
they improve student academic
performance and health both in the short
and long term and I provided you with a
lot of research that backs that up
um and it School meals decrease food
insecurity and that's especially
important right now because in the last
census household pulse 177
000 New Hampshire households with
children said that they did not have
sufficient food
that's an increase of 30 000 since this
past August
so it's critical that all children can
access meals in schools for many uh food
insecure families for the their children
those two meals in school are the only
meals that they're eating all day
um investments in child health and
academic success and investment in our
future so I urge you to support the bill
so that all New Hampshire children can
have an equal opportunity to succeed and
thrive
thank you very much uh are there any
questions from the committee
thank you and thank you for your written
report here appreciate it of course
thank you so much
and we have Becky Wilson then we're
going to follow it up at danwood
represent woodcock
good afternoon for the record Becky
Wilson of the New Hampshire school
boards Association uh we are in support
of House Bill 429 at our 2022 delegate
assembly our members passed a resolution
that focused solely on supporting any
legislation for state and federal
government to seek and provide viable
sustainable and permanent funding to
provide School breakfast and lunch at no
cost to all students and while this bill
is not specific to ensuring that there
is no cost to school districts per se it
does cover the fact that we want our
students to be fed I will not go into
all of the research because you've
already heard a lot of that and you've
had a very long day and many people have
already testified on the benefits of
feeding all of our students I will say
that during the pandemic when there was
waivers and relaxation of the
eligibility documentation that was
required for free and reduced lunch we
saw across the state enormous gains in
the number of students that would access
breakfast and lunch programs that are
already in existence and it is the
desire of our members to continue that
and to try to remove any stigma that
might affect students participation in
those programs we would ask potentially
I think it's already been brought up
that perhaps some kind of a amendment in
terms of if you are a district that is
already providing a breakfast or lunch
program outside of the federal breakfast
and lunch program that there would be
some sort of waiver to allow you to
continue to do that at the local cost of
the district that they've already
incurred if that is something that they
wish to do as long as you are providing
breakfast is available to all students
at a free or reduced cost as appropriate
we would also I'm not sure what the
reason is specifically that the 27
schools are not providing breakfast or
lunch we do have some districts in New
Hampshire that do not operate a school I
don't know if somehow that is being
incorporated into those numbers or if
those are specifically schools that are
not providing those programs but we
would just maybe ask for some
clarification around that to ensure that
we're getting the accurate data out
there and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much are there
questions for the school boards
Association
not seeing any thank you very much
ripson Woodcock do you have something
you want to
yes go ahead
thank you representative lad I apologize
for coming back uh representative
Harrigan mentioned the number of 153 of
schools in the state that we're
operating uh breakfast or lunch that was
an error representative Ellison and Miss
Rambo from doe corrected that and
brought us the correct data today all of
you have the correct data and the
financial note that came out and that
number is six not 153 but you want to go
out over the Airways as being the
incorrect information we got that that's
right thank you you're welcome um I I do
have one question of the department
Kelly do you have a moment
okay
it should be a very simple question for
you in the bill on lines of four and
five it says the State Board shall
establish minimum nutritional standards
is the state board setting the standards
or are the state are the standards set
by the National School breakfast program
um I believe that would be a question
for the State Board and not the
Department of Education
okay
[Music]
represent luck is
I'm hoping you can answer this question
or might have a hint
um do you have any idea why the schools
who aren't participating in the
breakfast or lunch programs are doing so
sure I can answer that thank you for the
question
um there if in the um the fiscal note
you'll see that there are a number of
different factors that could come into
play on why a school might not
participate in the breakfast program it
could be due to Staffing it could be due
to the timing of the buses this the not
only the kitchen staff or nutrition
staff that's available but the teachers
to watch the cafeteria and watch those
students so it's important to know that
for the breakfast program there are a
wide variety of factors that come into
play that might not be as challenging at
lunchtime when the school day has
started and you're already in your daily
routines for that so it's just important
to think about all of those things for
um for that program for breakfast
foreign
I'm sorry thank you
this would mandate that they provided
um so
is there additional expense are there
things that that we have to do to try to
help mitigate those issues because those
issues are real
there are reasons they're not providing
it so how are we dealing with that in
now mandating that they're going to
provide breakfast thank you for the
question um so also in the fiscal note
um the the costs due to being at the
local level are indeterminable at the
Department of Education but all of those
factors would come into play whether it
be that they need additional staff for
the breakfast time in the morning some
of the schools only have the nutrition
members for maybe staff members excuse
me for four hours five hours so that
would need to be taken into
consideration as well so for us at the
Department of Education those
um expenses would be indeterminable for
us to figure those out thank you so
Kelly before you get off the hook here
um working with this uh I'd like to have
some information on the question I asked
them the National School breakfast
program is administered through the
the department there must be something
coming through the department
and if so then if we're talking about
the State Board having to set these
minimum nutritional standards I would
assume there must be standards set by
the feds in terms of what is the
National School breakfast program and
I'm just you know if if this law says
right here or this bill says that we the
State Board is going to set that does
the State Board have the expertise to
set that if in fact you know if we're
going to be involved within are they
allowed to do it even if we're going to
be a part of the national breakfast
program which is federally directed so
there seems to be a little bit of
conflict here and I'd like to see some
resolution on this before we have to act
on it I will get an answer for you
um and I'm not sure if the state board
can um can speak to that but I will I
will look and and work on the answer for
that Allison just had his hand up and I
know he's involved with this all right
hopefully that I think that the State
Board is already written into the
legislation at this point
it doesn't doesn't deal with the issue
that should worry about what's the real
function of the State Board of Civic
nutritional standards so I think in the
existing law the State Board
yeah okay thank you
so I will work on clarification on that
clarifications
um is just simply a granola bar
I will get clarification for you on that
um to your question on the standards for
the USDA program yes just like just like
lunch there are standards for um for
breakfast for the USDA program yeah
thank you that's exactly where I'm going
further questions from the committee
yes reps in balbooni
thank you Mr chair
um just another question to follow up on
yeah so those six districts that don't
have
um either program right now the costs
will be borne by those districts than
the full costs to assume the programs
that's correct
so just a quick follow-up
um so they would actually have to
prepare for that in advance and go to
the towns with a budget increase
done that's correct as the bill is
written those six schools would be
affected by the bill correct all right
thank you representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um if if those schools signed up for the
federal school program how much money
would it cost them per pupil for a
breakfast meal and for a lunch meal do
you have any idea unfortunately at the
Department of Education that is
indeterminable all the local that's
local control for the cost per price how
much it would cost per student again
thinking of all of those factors if they
are not currently running a program if
they don't currently have a kitchen they
would need to implement all of those
um those things and Equipment staff
there's a number of things that that
could go into to that to that cost for
them to start a program thank you
representative leckers
just for clarification so then the that
estimate on the fiscal note
um
that's
that's what does that cover and then
um
so then our end for the rest of the cost
for somebody who has to set up a kitchen
or whatever they have to do
is that then where is that been an
unfunded mandate
or is this money that's that's the state
cost here that's in the fiscal note is
that to cover it I'm not sure what that
covers sure
um in The Narrative of the fiscal note
there um is a state expenditures and
then a local expenditures
um the money that is associated with
that and please note this fiscal note
was also written with the charter
schools still
um in place there so that's why you'll
see
um the the need for two additional staff
members at the Department of Education
to manage those additional charter
schools that would would need to operate
for that so the state expenditures that
are listed on the fiscal note are
specifically for what it would be at the
Department of Education and not at the
local level
thank you very much thank you for the
questions
thank you very much Kelly thank you
so I have no further pink cards on this
one so we are going to close the hearing
and we're a little bit late but we're
going to take about five minutes here
for those that get up for a second here
and and we'll come back in about five
minutes
next one is the last one
I bet you that's where I bet you'll be
helping file somewhere along the way
we'll find it
okay so I'd like to go ahead and open up
the hearing for 424 this is uh relative
to school lunch payment policies and
recognize guys represent Tim Horrigan
the prime sponsor of the bill
thank you very much I continue to be
representative Tim Horrigan I continue
to lift something unexpectedly has
happened I'm still continuing to
represent Stratford County District 10
which is now just the town of Durham
and uh actually this bill this exact
same bill almost passed three years ago
it uh passed on the consent calendar
during the marathon session before the
pandemic hit and then it kind of uh got
lost in the shuffle after the pandemic
and the Senate tabled it
then I tried again the next year with
less success but maybe the third time
will be the charm um it's fairly simple
it uh HB 424 requires students to serve
the same lunch to every child regardless
of whether or not his or her family
already owes a lunch debt and so
unfortunately this is a growing problem
especially with the economic turmoil of
the last few years but um doesn't
abolish the humility practice for
providing a separate and not quite equal
meal to a child who cannot pay for his
or her lunch
and it also um
prohibits public identification or
stigmatation of a student who's welcomes
parents but who cannot pay for a meal or
who owes a eight meal debt no matter how
subtle you try to make it uh kids are
very sensitive to a Nuance especially
when it comes to issues of you know
Financial issues and the it's a it also
prohibits
so they can't force privileged child who
cannot pay a meal from a Rose of meal
death from being forced to do chores or
other work to pay for meals unless
chores or other work are required of all
students so
and I don't actually know many cases
cases of that but um and also it
requires schools to get Direct
Communications about a child's meal debt
to a parent or guardian and not to the
student which
aside from not embarrassing a student
that's a good practice because it's more
likely to get to the uh the parent if
you contact them directly rather than
you know sending a note with the
children and you know there's
we haven't we haven't had the worship
abuses here in New Hampshire but in
other states some very humiliating uh
things things have happened you know
even
I think I'd say even though
sometimes even one school district even
stamped on the uh in another state
stamped like a message in the forehand
was something like like I owe lunch I
owe my old lunch debt which is like just
you know not a not a good thing to do so
this is um
Bill uh it's been passed in other states
I think there's even some federal
legislation along these lines so I think
it's a pretty uh pretty simple thing
that adds to the protections that are
already in place in
in the in the in the rsas and I uh urge
you to uh do what we did in 2020 and and
uh and passage preferably unanimously on
the consent calendar would be nice but
as long as you pass it I'm happy so I'd
be also happy to take any questions
should anyone have have any
thank you very much can I see are there
any questions for representative Oregon
representative
yes I remember this Bill yes
um
my question is and thank you for
answering my question well I haven't
done it yet but I probably will do
yes
um
my question is are you aware of any
issues that are currently taking place
in our street because I seem to remember
that when this was up before being told
that this has already been taken care of
and that it's not happening so I'm
wondering
what you know of this
I mean there's a there's already some
some protections for these are very
explicit protections these are certainly
especially abusive practices that it
would
specifically uh specifically
specifically for beds and actually don't
really
although I voted for the consent
calendar when this failed in 2021 I
don't necessarily agree with what the
member who wrote the committee report
said about it although
she's no longer on this committee so I
guess I don't have to worry that much
about what she said but um I mean I
think I think this is uh I think this is
uh I think we got it right the first
time in 2020 and we should uh we should
pass this because our it's sort of
addressing the existing law but but but
not really and um certainly lunch lunch
debt is uh it's it's a growing it's a
growing problem uh you know it's a
growing problem Nationwide here in New
Hampshire especially we had uh we had
the free lunches when the federal
funding was available during the
pandemic and this doesn't restore the
free lunches but that was an extremely
popular program so if you get if you get
a bill along those lines the parents
will will love you if we will love us if
we pass it but it um
and so there's a is there a lot of a lot
of the issue a lot of it is either
family a lot of his families who are
eligible for the reduced price meal but
don't apply for it and then paying the
full price meal and then are unable to
pay for the full price meal because they
underestimated uh
how good their financial situation was
so that's just I think that's probably
the main source of it and that's just
sometimes uh parents who neglect to pay
and also another another advantage of
doing uh unless this collection activity
is it's fairly it's fairly expensive to
collect all these small debts and there
are um
there are contractors that do it for the
schools but um I think probably the you
know we
a lot of this a lot of the debt
collection activities kind of kind of a
waste of of effort and money in my
opinion but that's um
so that's that's kind of a long answer
to your short question I don't know how
much I don't know if that's if you're
satisfied or not but they can you
put this accordingly uh thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you representative
um as you said we've had this bill a
couple of times
um and it seems to me
um
my recollection might be faulty but
perhaps you can tell me if um there are
instances of a child being required to
do chores in order to pay off a school
that I I thought we had discussed this
in the past and there that was not
taking place well my I don't know
there's few examples of even children
here in the New Hampshire
School District who do chores at school
I know they're the closest thing I can
the closest the closest thing I know
specifically is we have uh there's a
number of schools in my in my area
including each one of my local
Cooperative school districts which have
a farm to table program so they have a
you know they have like a garden which
grows vegetables for use in the using
the cafeteria and that's um
although that's probably yeah so you
wouldn't be able to force your kid to
work on the farm to table Garden if you
didn't want to just because he had a
lunch debt so I think although I seem
probably all the students who were doing
that are doing so voluntarily or as part
of an instructional program I mean
there's some other something that may be
copied to some of the charter schools I
don't know which is true in other
countries other countries uh
do expect school children to do chores
around the uh around the around the
school I know even uh I just go for a
year in England they would sometimes
have us show a few things like painting
the walls and the Courtyard at the
school or something which is not not
really the practice here in New
Hampshire but there may be some uh maybe
some Charter Schools or other special
programs doing it you know the famous
example of course is in Japan we're at
the end of every school day they push
all the desks and chairs to the wall and
make the kids sweep the floor before
they go which uh not something we do to
the United States but there could be
some Public Charter School here in New
Hampshire who thinks that's a good idea
and has the children doing it but I
don't know for sure yes I I think and
maybe I missed it again but I think you
said you don't know that that happens in
HR school is that what I heard yes I
don't know specifically you may uh okay
thank you
for the questions representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
I'm having a bit of confusion around
lines 12 through 14.
um any school participates in the
National School breakfast program or the
national school lunch program shall not
provide to any child who qualifies for
fruit use if breakfast or lunch an
alternate meal that is not provided to
the students generally yeah now I
haven't spent a lot of time at various
schools but I know when I went to school
there was there was tended to be
multiple different options available so
what
can you clarify if this for instance
including vendors some schools bring in
vendors and whatnot would this require a
school to allow a child to have a choice
of anything including vendors that may
be higher priced or something like that
um I don't think so I think what the uh
the example that I've heard about this
has happened in certainly many other
states which is uh you know let the kid
have the hot lunch but they give them
something like uh well sunflower butter
give him her sunflower butter sandwich
or a cheese sandwich or something that's
not available to the other children it
certainly doesn't um doesn't forbid uh
doesn't prevent the school lunch program
or practice from offering the children
the choice of entrees and certainly um
it doesn't provide anyone regardless of
their family's financial situation from
bringing in their own home lunch if they
prefer so those are still allowable
practices and
um so I'm not sure
not not sure what not sure if that
answers you not sure if that's I'm not
sure what more there is to say about it
but yet that doesn't you can still
provide multiple meals to the kids they
don't all have to eat the same thing if
are there other other questions yes just
to clarify a little bit what I what I
meant was when I went to school anyway
we had vendors come in for instance we
had Domino's Pizza and you could just go
in and purchase Domino's Pizza as part
of your lunch with this the way this is
written here would this require schools
to then cover the cost of students who
wanted to get from those vendors instead
of from the school cafeteria I would
I would I would uh
I would assume that it would not require
them to cover the cost of any outside
vendors or selling food that uh
isn't but that the schools aren't paying
for now and of course they're going to
be a lot more expensive to pay Domino's
for the lunch than the school lunch
program but
um I'm frankly I'm I'm like I was born
in 1956 so this was not going on when I
was in the public school in the mid 70s
so I that's a
I mean if you think there's an issue you
might want to look into that but I I
don't know if I don't think that would
forbid that practice
further questions
yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Horgan lens four and five
say prohibit public identification or
stigmatization of a student who cannot
pay for a meal is this to prevent
discrimination against students of a
certain socioeconomic status
um well that would uh
would be highly correlated with
socioeconomic status I mean may also
just have kids who's a parents have are
leading disorganized life even though
they may be making it making a good
income but that would be or just like
not only questions like to associate the
idea is that you're only supposed to
tell uh you're only supposed to tell the
you know the parents the administrator
keeping a need to know policy so not
informing you know the general School
population or the public outside the
school of which kids it is who are
paying the luncheon escorts highly
correlated with your social economic
status but there may be
maybe people like some papers of mine
who
their father was kind of disorganized
and they're always getting the
electricity cut off and that sort of
thing but he was actually making a very
good salary he was just sort of a
disorganized person but most cases
that'd be social economic status would
probably be highly correlated with it
but thanks looks like it will follow up
so go ahead yeah
so but the intent is to prevent
discrimination against certain students
yes yes as kids aren't the kids whose
parents aren't paying the lunch debt
they shouldn't be uh harassed or
stigmatized by their peers or even by
their teachers no
thank you for the question yes for
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair and thank you for being here I
noticed that the bill doesn't
designate how this should be enforced if
a parent or a child even reports that
they've been stigmatized or that their
child's been stigmatized so how do you
envision that this is really enforced at
the local level or even at the state
level
well if they're uh I mean I guess the
parents could that the policy was
violated uh you would want them to just
take corrective action and stop fighting
the process they could lead to lawsuits
an extreme thing and if and if a parent
runs up
an excessive lunch debt you know they
can uh you know they can the school can
collect on the debt I suppose they could
even uh even sue them in extreme cases I
think most most of the time this is
relatively small number of dollars so
like it's uh probably uh it can probably
be a the upper the cost can probably be
be absorbed but uh and also there have
been some cases where uh benefactors
even here in New Hampshire benefactors
you know outside
what's outside benefactors uh some
generous local person will occasionally
just uh
give the school money to pay off all the
outstanding lunch debts so that's um
are there further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you thank you and there are no
other pink cards we have on so we will
close this hearing
and this concludes the hearings for
today
uh Mr chair can I see the them's out in
the hallway please tell me I need to see
the demons out in the hallway oh okay
okay thank you yeah
um
one thing I wanted to mention to all the
committee members here is that when we
hear bills now we can exec a bill
following the hearing even though it may
not be listed as such executive session
may follow if in fact that both
representative Miler and I agree that we
want to move forward with that bill so
we can get unanimous consent and move
forward and get that done it's a quick
way to get some bills on the consent
calendar we're going to run into a real
heavy roadblock here with 91 bills
piling up on us if we can unload some of
these into upcoming sessions it would be
really helpful so
thank you very much and the Democrats
want to meet out in the hallway I guess
there's well probably a room across the
hall too you could use
um
represent Meyer is throwing you out
gonna stay here all night long if you
want
go forth
yes
9 30 tomorrow right yes 9 30 tomorrow
morning here
the other thing what we ought to be
doing here